COMPLETING OUR SECOND HEARING
OF SEAT WILL RISE AS SELECT
COMMITTEE ON SEA LEVEL RISE IN
THE CALIFORNIA ECONOMY. WE KNOW
THAT TIME IT CHANGE IS
HAPPENING AND WE SEE THAT IN
OUR WILDFIRE WE SEE THAT
INCREASED HEAT EVENTS- I'M AND
WE'RE INCREASINGLY SEEING THAT
WAS C. LEVEL RISE. I THINK WELL
I REPRESENT A COASTAL DISTRICT
DOWN IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY- YOU
GUYS ARE PROBABLY SAYING UP
MORE FREQUENTLY AND MORE
URGENTLY THAN SOME OF THE REST
THE STATE SO IT'S GREAT TO BE
HERE. IN THE BAY AREA- AND I'M
FIRST LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
SPEAKER WHICH TIME KEVIN
MULLIN- FOR HOSTING THIS
HEARING IN HIS DISTRICT ALSO
THANK THE STAFF WORKING WITH MY
STUFF BUT THIS HEARING
TOGETHER. AND THEIR HARD WORK
IS VERY MUCH APPRECIATED I'D
ALSO LIKE TO WELCOME MIKE SOME
OF THEM YOU KNOW WELL BECAUSE
THE REPRESENTS MADERA COUNTY-
WE HAVE AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARK
STONE WE HAVE SENATOR JERRY
HELL AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARC
BERMAN WILL BE HERE SHORTLY.
AND THIS IS NOT EMILY WAS A SUB
WHILE BUT THERE LIGHT. THIS
LIKE A MAYOR SAVAGE. AGO MY
FORMER ASSEMBLY WHICH WERE WITH
A TODAY. IT'S AN HONOR TO CARRY
ON HIS PART. AND IT'S AN HONOR
TO CARRY ON WITH THE SELECT
COMMITTEE REALLY THE WORK THAT
YOU STARTED AND WORK. ENDS AND
SOME WAYS A LITTLE BIT TO LATER
ON. AND WE KNOW THAT THERE'S
MAJOR INVESTMENTS THAT WE'RE
GOING TO MAKE THE STATE'S MAJOR
POLICY IS THAT WE NEED TO LOOK
AT. SOME OF THOSE
CONVERSATIONS. ARE NOT EASY-
AND SO I'D LIKE TO ASK
EVERYBODY HERE TODAY LET'S
THINK ABOUT HOW WE CAN WORK
OTHER HOW WE CAN BRING. OUR
ISSUES TOGETHER AND REALLY HELP
MAKE SURE WE HAVE A CALIFORNIA
FOR THE FUTURE I'M A MOTHER OF
TWO KIDS I WANNA MAKE SURE. IS
A CALIFORNIA THAT THEY CAN LIVE
IN. SO MANY OF OUR GOVERNMENTS
ARE ENGAGING EVERITT DRIVE
ADDRESS THE IMPACT OF SEA LEVEL
RISE. AND WE'RE STRUCTURING
THESE HEARINGS REALLY GIVING
OPPORTUNITY FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. TELL US WHAT
THEY'RE DOING ALL THEY'VE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL WHAT THEY NEED FROM
US AND DON'T JUST SAY MONEY AS
WE KNOW THAT- BUT WHAT IS IT
THAT ON THE POLICIES THAT THEY
NEED. OUR REGIONAL AGENCIES
WORKING TO TOGETHER TO ADDRESS
THE LEVEL RISE AND THERE WILL
ALSO BE HEARING FROM EXPERTS.
IN THE FIELD OF CLIMATE CHANGES
LEVEL RISE- BUT BEFORE WE GO
FORWARD AND LOOK AT THIS- AND
BEFORE PANEL BEGINS. I'D LIKE
TO OPEN UP MY COLLEAGUES.
OPENING REMARKS. ASSEMBLY OF
THE SENATE. APPROACH THEM
MULLIN. THANK YOU SO MUCH. AND
THANK YOU FOR. THIS HEARING IN
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT AND TWO MORE
IMPORTANTLY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS. ISSUE WE
ARE GOING TO BE DEALING WITH
THIS. HERE AND FOR MANY YEARS
I'M- AND I WOULD LIKE TO ALSO-
ACKNOWLEDGE MY COLLEAGUES FROM
THE SENATE SENATOR HILL WHO'S
BEEN AN INCREDIBLE PARTNER. NOT
TO MEET- I WILL BE SAD TO SEE
LEAVE OFFICE LEAVE THE SENATE
AT THE END OF THIS YEAR BUT I
HOPE WE CONTINUE OUR
PARTNERSHIP IN A PUBLIC
CAPACITY- SO THANK YOU SIR FOR
BEING HERE AND MY A COLLIE OUT
FROM THE SOUTH. FROM THE
SECRETARY ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE
AND I KNOW THAT- I BELIEVE THE
ONLY MEMBER BERMAN WILL BE
JOINING US AS WELL AND OUR
FORMER ASSEMBLY ALLEY. JORDAN
THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE
TODAY. AND FOR HOSTING THIS
IMPORTANT DISCUSSION IN MY
DISTRICT. I CAN THINK OF NO
BETTER PLACE TO HAVE THIS
COMMITTEE HEARING THAT RIGHT
HERE IN FOSTER CITY. WHICH HAS
BEEN ON THE FOREFRONT OF
PLANNING FOR CLIMATE CHANGE AT
AFTER. WITH THEIR LEVY PLAN
WHICH YOU WILL LEARN ABOUT.
TODAY AS MANY OF YOU ALREADY
ARE WHERE UNFORTUNATELY I
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THIS COUNTY.
OF SAN MATTEO IS PROJECTED TO
BE ONE OF THE MOST IMPACTED IN
THE STATE. WHEN IT COMES TO
CLIMATE CHANGE DUE TO SEA LEVEL
RISE IN THE LEVEL RISE WE HAVE
CHALLENGES BOTH ON OUR BASE
SIDE OF COURSE AND- ON OUR
COASTLINE WE ARE ALREADY SEEING
THAT PLAY OUT. AS YOU AS WE
DEAL WITH COASTAL EROSION.
ALONG THE SAN MATEO COUNTY
COAST AS THE SEA LEVELS RISE
THE EAST SIDE OF HIGHWAY ONE A
ONE. ALONG WITH SFO ARE AT RISK
OF BEING INUNDATED BY FLOODING.
THE PROPERTY LOSSES THE
ECONOMIC LOSSES IN THE LOSS OF
BASIC SERVICES SUCH AS POWER.
SEWER SYSTEMS ARE REAL IMPACT
OF SEA LEVEL RISE. THAT WE MUST
PLAN FOR. ACCORDING TO THE U.
S. G. S. IN THE PACIFIC
INSTITUTE ONE HUNDRED BILLION.
WE SAY THAT AGAIN. ONE HUNDRED
BILLION. OF THE ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY BILLION IN SHORELINE
ECONOMIC ASSETS AT RISK FROM
SEA LEVEL RISE IN CALIFORNIA.
IS RIGHT HERE. IN THE BAY AREA
SAN MATTEO COUNTIES RISK ALONE
IS ESTIMATED AT TWENTY FOUR.
BILLION SEA LEVEL RISE IS REAL
AND IT IS HAPPENING NOW. WHICH
IS WHY WE HAVE TO ACT. WHILE WE
STILL CAN THERE IS AN URGENCY
HERE. I TOOK A REAL URGENCY
THAT WE NEED TO ARTICULATE FOR
THE BROADER PUBLIC. WITH THAT
SAID I WOULD LIKE TO ONCE AGAIN
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR HOSTING
THIS HEARING IN MY DISTRICT I
LOOK FORWARD TO A VERY
INFORMATIVE DISCUSSION. THAT
WOULD SAY. OVER THE COURSE OF
THE NEXT STUFF YOU MIND SEVEN
POOR TO ADVOCATING. FOR THE
ASSEMBLY IS VERSION OF THE
CLIMATE RESILIENCY BONDS.
CURRENTLY BEING DRAFTED
LANGUAGES BEING. UP CORD- AND
CONSIDER. AND MY SINCERE HOPE
IS THAT ANY BOND. THAT MAKES IT
TO THE BALLOT ACKNOWLEDGES THE
MAGNITUDE. OF THE CHALLENGE
THAT WE ARE DEALING WITH. NOT
ONLY IN THE BAY AREA BUT ROUTE.
THE STATE WITH THAT THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND THE POOR TO A
ROBUST DISCUSSION. THERE THAT
WERE ON MEDICARE VERY HAPPY TO
BE HERE IN THE MOUNTAINS.
CENTER HILLS DISTRICT ON A
CONVERSATION THAT IS CAN BE A
LITTLE BIT LEAK AS WE LOOK FOR
FORWARD TO THE CHALLENGES THAT
REALLY HAVE. BUT KNOWING WITH
HIM TAIL COUNTY HAS AND WE'RE
GONNA BE HEARING FROM THEM
KNOWING WHAT THE BAY AREA HAS
DONE REALLY IN LEADING
CALIFORNIA AND I WE THIS
COUNTRY AND I'M VERY VERY
DIFFICULT CONVERSATIONS. IT'S
APPROPRIATE THAT WE HAVE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE OF LISTEN TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND THE CHALLENGES
THAT HAVE. OVER THE DECADES
DONE A LOT REALLY DID START
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS OF
RESOURCES. AND THE ABILITY TO
ADAPT TO THE SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES THAT WE'RE GOING TO
SEE. THAT AS WE TALK ABOUT
RESOURCE BONDS IN SPECIALLY
WE'RE GONNA BE SELLING THIS TO
THE PUBLIC AS A RESILIENCE. IF
WE'RE NOT CAREFUL AND IF THE
STATE IS WILLING TO SET
STANDARDS HAVE CONVERSATIONS
LIKE THIS LOOKING AT. PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT ROAD MAP LIKE THE
LA REPORT. FIRST WHAT WE'RE
FIRST GOING TO BE HEARING FROM.
ON ANIL TODAY IF WE'RE NOT
WILLING TO ALSO HELP LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS WITH THE PLANNING
AND THE REGIONAL NEEDS THEN
IT'S DIFFICULT TO UNDERSTAND
HOW THIS GETS DONE FROM THE
STATE'S IMPORT I AM HOPING THAT
WE ARE WILLING TO. SET
STANDARDS THAT WE ARE WILLING
TO ENCOURAGE LOCALS TO DO
BROADER REGIONAL COOPERATION
AROUND PLANNING EFFORTS AND
REALLY LOOKING AT WHAT NEEDS TO
GET AND THEN OF COURSE WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO BE PUTTING
RESOURCES ON THE TAPE. BONDS
AND OTHER MECHANISMS IN ORDER
TO MEET THE FINANCIAL
CHALLENGES THAT THIS REPRESENTS
NOT JUST FOR. TERMS AS GO BAY
AREA BUT THE ENTIRE COAST OF
CALIFORNIA THESE ARE DAUNTING
ISSUES AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT
MANY JURISDICTIONS ARE NOT.
HAVING US HARD TIME LOOKING
HONESTLY AT THESE ISSUES
BECAUSE OF THOSE IMPLICATIONS
THE FISCAL IMPLICATIONS. AND
THE POLITICAL IMPLICATIONS.
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THOSE
CHANGES ARE COMING TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES. AND WHAT THE
REALITIES ARE SO THAT CREATES A
VERY DIFFICULT LANDSCAPE I
THINK TO OPERATE IN THAT'S WHY
GOOD DATA GOOD INFORMATION
WILLINGNESS TO COLLABORATE
AMONG LOCAL JURISDICTIONS BUT
ALSO WITH THE STATE TRULY AS A
PARTNER IN HELPING TO SET THOSE
STANDARDS I'VE BEEN WITH
RESOURCES AND MAKE SURE ALL OF
THESE. CAN BE ADDRESSED AS WE
MOVE FORWARD. THERE'S TOO MUCH
AT STAKE NOT TOO THAT WE
RECOGNIZE THAT HERE IT'S NOT
RECOGNIZED EVERYWHERE
ESPECIALLY AROUND THIS COUNTRY
UNFORTUNATELY AT THIS TIME IT'S
STILL FREE ELSE BUT LEAD PUT
TOGETHER GOOD PLANS MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE HOUSE OF
EMPLOYMENT AND THEN WE CAN DO A
LOT ON THIS ISSUE OF OUR TIME
IT'S AND BUILDING TO RESILIENCE
IN CALIFORNIA BUT FOR THE
DISCUSSION TODAY. THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR IN IN FIRST OF ALL
THANK YOU. SHIP IT IN AND
AROUND THIS ISSUE. IF IT'S A
SAN DIEGO CALIFORNIA LEGISLATOR
RARELY SEEN THEM IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA BUT THIS IS A REALLY
EXCEPTIONAL AND IT'S BECAUSE OF
YOUR MEMBERSHIP AND THE
RECOGNITION THAT THIS IS A
STATE WIDE AND A PROBLEM SO
THANK YOU VERY VERY MUCH FOR
HAVING THE HEARING HERE IS THIS
REALLY IS I THINK THE EPICENTER
OF A LOT OF THE PROBLEMS THAT
MACHINE I DON'T WANT TO REPEAT
WHAT LIKE GOOD COLLEAGUES SAID-
BUT- THEY HIT THE NAIL ON THE
HEAD AND THE CHALLENGES THAT WE
FIND STRUGGLES OF REGIONAL
ISSUES OR REGIONAL SOLUTIONS TO
THIS BECAUSE IT DOESN'T JUST
END OF THE CITY BORDER. OR
COUNTY BORDER AND THAT'S REALLY
WHAT WE HAVE TO FIND AND I WANT
TO THANK THE ASSEMBLY I THANK
THE ASSEMBLY FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP- IN MOVING THIS AND
IT CERTAINLY TO FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GORDON FOR HIS
INSIGHT AT THE TIME TO BRING
THIS FORWARD AS A PROBLEM
BEFORE IT BECAME A BEFORE
PEOPLE THOUGHT WAS THE SERIES
IS SERIOUS AND IT IS IT IS THEN
IT WAS AND IS TODAY. IS IT SO
MUCH PRESSURE TO GET TO THE OF
PROP WERE HERE FOR TODAY TO YOU
AND EVERY THAT AND THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR VERY VERY MUCH.
WHAT IS ONE OF THE FALL ON.
OVER PEOPLE PEOPLE'S BECAUSE
I'M- THIS NEWS SO I. IN ADVANCE
FOR YOUR FOR DOING THAT BUT WE
WANT TO START OFF BY THANKING.
ALL I GUESS I'M A MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH- FOR CONVENING
THIS IMPORTANT CONVERSATION
ESPECIALLY- IN THE BAY AREA- IT
AND SOMETIME BEFORE MATH AND I.
BOERNER HORVATH AND I HAVE HAVE
SERVED TOGETHER FOR A LITTLE
OVER A YEAR NOW- AND I'VE
LEARNED THAT WHEN SHE PUTS HER
MIND SET IN THE NEW ISSUE WHEN
YOU PUT YOUR MIND INTO
SOMETHING. GET OUT OF THE WAY-
AND THEN GET ON BOARD- AND SO
WE AND WE NEED THAT KIND OF
LEADERSHIP- ESPECIALLY ON. THIS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT ISSUE- AND
DEFINITELY WANT TO. THANK MY
PREDECESSOR RICH GORDON- WHEN I
GOT ELECTED MY STAFF SAID TO ME
WELL YOUR PREDECESSORS AYE
MEMBER GORDON HAD THIS AMAZING
SELECT COMMITTEE ON SEAL OR-
AS- A AND I SAID LOOK I CAN'T
DO EVERYTHING RICH DID. I NEED
TO SEPARATE MYSELF A LITTLE
BIT. EXCEPT FOR MY FIRST BILL.
I INTRODUCED IT WHICH WAS
EXTENDING US SOMETHING THAT MY
PREDECESSOR HAD WHICH WAS
CREATING A PREPARING FOR SEA
LEVEL RISE DATABASE- THAT
BECAUSE IN THE LEGISLATURE WE
DON'T DO ANYTHING PERMANENTLY-
IT HAD A SUN. DATE ON IT THAT
WAS SO EARLY THAT THE DATABASE
WAS HARDLY EVEN SET UP. BY THE
TIME IT WAS GOING TO SUNSET AND
SO MY FIRST BILL. AND IT WAS IT
EIGHTY FOUR- WAS SAID TO IT
CONTINUE ON THE GOOD WORK THAT
MY PREDECESSOR I HAD DONE. BUT
A- S. BOERNER HORVATH. WHEN
WRITTEN ABOUT THIS AND SHE TO
ME THAT SHE DOING A- IT'S LIKE
COMMITTEE. HEARING IN FOSTER
CITY SHE WAS. ME YOU CAN A FAQ
AND DATA. ABOUT FOSTER SAY THAT
I EVEN KNOW AND THEN HUNDREDS
AND HUNDREDS OF MILES AWAY FROM
HER DESK. SO REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR PASSION. ISSUE I REALLY
LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING FROM
ALL THE EXPERTS WE'VE HAD- OVER
THE SEA SUPERVISOR PINE IN THE-
MAN'S WHO'S BEEN LEADING ON
THIS. THE ISSUE FOR MANY YEARS
I REMEMBER. I THINK I SAW YOU
THE SUPERVISOR PINE IS A MEMBER
GORDON AT A- AT A- WHERE THEY
CALL THEM THE- BRUISING VIEWS-
ADD. HAVE MADE BREWING COMPANY.
BEFORE I WAS EVER ELECTED TO
THE ASSEMBLY. SO LOOKING
FORWARD TO. TO LEARNING FROM
EVERYBODY IN THE AUDIENCE TODAY
THANKS. THANK YOU WHAT THAT.
WILL COOPER FOR PANEL. AND THAT
IS RICH ALERT WHOSE ARE PER.
FISCAL POLICY ANALYST AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE-
TO DOCTOR ABOUT PREPARING FOR
RISING SEAS. HOW THE STATE CAN
HELP SUPPORT LOCAL COASTAL
ADAPTATION EFFORTS. THANK YOU
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON RACHEL
EHLERS WITH THAT LA- THINK YOU
SO MUCH FOR HAVING ME HERE
TODAY. AND WE'VE GOT A TIGHT
AGENDA SO I'M GONNA START MY
TIMER SO I DON'T GO TOO FAR TO
HAVE THE. SO I'LL BE SPEAK
TODAY ABOUT A REPORT THAT OUR
OFFICE PUT OUT IN DECEMBER-
WHICH AS YOU ALL HAVE A COPY OF
AND THERE'S AN EXECUTIVES.
THREE PAGE TWO IS ALSO
AVAILABLE ON OUR WEBSITE.
OTHERS WERE NOT HERE. SO WE
NEED. IN THIS COURT BECAUSE WE
FELT LIKE THE STATION STARTING
BROADEN INSIDE AND OUT IT'S
BEEN A LOT OF TIME TALKING
ABOUT CLIMATE MITIGATION. THE
PAST TWO YEARS AND A LOT OF. US
BUT THE BUT OF DISCUSSION START
IN ABOUT WELL WITH. SOME
IMPACTS I MAGIC. COME AND WE
READ DEAL I'M- HOW ARE WE TO. I
AM. THIS REPORT WAS A RESPONSE
THAT. BROWN NUMBER SESSION AT.
GOT A STATEWIDE BACK BUT- MAY
ALSO AREA THE STATE AND IT
REALLY FOCUSED ON. CAN THIS.
HELP LOWER MAKE US THIS ISSUE I
TALKED FOR A HUNDRED PEOPLE
ALRIGHT MUCH AS WE COULD TALK
MAYBE BECAUSE AT A TWO HAVE A
INFORMED PROCESS. SO I WANT TO
MEET AND TALK ABOUT WHAT YEAH I
AM OR PROJECT WILL BE A
PARTICULARLY BECAUSE YOU'RE
SUBSEQUENT PANELS WILL TALK LOT
MORE ABOUT THE IN. BUT WE KNOW
IT'S COMING WE KNOW CA BE
SEVERE HERE. A ALONG COAST
THERE'S PRETTY PRETTY GOOD
SCIENTIFIC CONSENSUS THE SINGLE
IS WILL BE BE HALF OF IT AND
BUT WITHIN NEXTAG A LITTLE BIT
MORE UNCERTAINTY BY AND OF THE
TREE BUT I AM. TO SEVEN FEET
MOTHER RECENT KIND OF A DAY
SUGGEST THAT COULD BE FROM
MARS. IT'S NOT. THE THING SEAT
BUT ALSO PACKS STORE AND TIED
IT WILL BRING WATER AT. THE
MORE EPISODE PLEASE. THEY'RE
STILL STRUCTURES THAT THEY'RE
GONNA BUT EVEN IF IT'S NOT A
PROBLEM INK AND WE LEVEL. SO I
HAVE IT TAX IN OUR IN FOR
ACTION. SOURCE ONE OF UNITY
PRIVATE. HE'S I THINK THESE ARE
THAT IMPACT FROM ANALYSTS. THIS
IS FROM MY ROOM AND I THINK
IT'S BLOWN UP HERE IN A DURING
HIM IS WELL. I'M ISN'T IS FOR
USING A TOOL OR BY THE CDC OURS
AGENCY HERE IN THE BAY. AT THAT
TAX DIFFERENT FLOODING. THE TWO
ZERO LAURA IN YOUR DORM IN THE
STORE MIKE ANSWER READ NEARLY
CAN SEE BOTTOM LEFT CORNER OF
THE IMAGE IS BY UP PICTURE
STIRS YOU WERE SITTING RIGHT
NOW IS PRETTY I'M NOT THIS IS
AB ANY I. ACTION ADVENTURE THIS
IS FOR IS DOING. SO MOST OF THE
WORK IS IN TO HAPPEN HELLO
LEVEL BUT THAT DOES THE STATE
ALSO HAVE A VESTED IN IN PRINT
AND TAKE ACTION NOW EAT BUT
FEEL THE IMPACTS OF AWAY AWAY A
AND BRING. ED CANNOT MUST DO IS
IN COST. TIME I'M A CO LAO S.
TO TRY PRINCE. FOR DIFFERENT
AREAS REALLY ONLY A LOT TO TAKE
SOME AGES TO BE THIS IS YOUR
CHANCE TO DON'T KNOW WHAT WOULD
WORK. AND WE CAN TRY THINGS OUT
DO YOU THINK WORK OR NOT AND
THEN REPLICATE M. L. OR. KATE
IS WE THE TIME OUR WE START NOW.
SO WITH WHAT IS THE STATUS OF
THE STATE. CAPTION BY LOCAL GOT
ENDS WITH A LOT OF WORK IS DONE
BUT REALLY NEED AN OFFICE IS OF
A SINGLE THE BILL THE STARTING
TO MAYBE HI LEVEL ADEPT IN PLAN
AND IS STARTING TO THINK. I'M
PROUD. BUT REALLY VERY FEW
SHORT CHECKS HAPPENING BUT
BROWN ACROSS THE STATE. THE
EARLY PHASE OF RATIONS NOW WE
WILL CHARACTER I. SO WE KNOW.
BUT JUST BEING ME KNOWS IT'S
AREAS. FOR ANY AND PRIVATE X.
SEC THREE IN THE PAST BUT I
THINK WHICH RELATED FUNDING.
BUT ALSO EXPERT IS AND THAT'S
PARTLY BECAUSE THIS IS A NEW
FIELD AND THEIR LIMITED EXPERT
IS IN FIELD ON THE STATE AND
OVER THE BRAND OF THE WORLD SO
IT PARTY IN FOR LOCAL GOT THEM
I'M A JET TO PARIS AT THE NEXT
TO END PRETTY. CROSSED STATE.
THIRD ALLEN IS INFORMATION IN
THIS TESTING OR SEND US IT
SHOULD BE HER INFORMATION OF
YOU KNOW NOT FOR THE FIRST IN
HIS TO BE OUR SEVERE TO BE
ACTUALLY SOME GOOD TO PUT A BIT
DEVELOPED. OR DO WE DO ABOUT
THAT. SO NO ONE ON THE THESE
ARE WHAT OF. SHOULD WE ON HOW
MUCH DO THOSE. HOW DO WE WAY
THE TRADE OFFS OF THOSE
PROJECTS AND IT'S JUST AGAIN
THIS LIMITED INFORMATION AROUND
THE STATE AND NOT REALLY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS EXPRESSING NOT
REALLY KNOWING WHO TO TURN TO
FIND OUT SOME OF THOSE ANSWERS.
THE FOURTH CHALLENGE. SUCH SOME
THE COOK SENATE. IS REALLY
ABOUT CUSTER'S TO ALL AND READ
NO PLANNING. AND RESEARCH AND
NOT REALLY HAVE FOR TO HELP
THOSE. OF COME XIN. PART THREE
BODY WITH THEIR EVERYDAY
RESPONSIBILITIES AND SO BUT WE
DOWN THE WALLS NINE FORM SPEAK
THE WATER IS NOT STOP THE CITY
COUNTY NINE. INSTEAD IN ONE
SIX. WILL BACKED. UP IN THE NAY
JURISDICTION. THREE CHALLENGE
HEARD WHAT ABOUT A LITTLE
MESSAGE THIS BUDGET. RT AT THE
SENATE AND THEREFORE FOR OF
THAT ELECTED OFFICIAL I AM THE
WITH. HOUSING ISSUES AND
HOMELESS ISSUES AND EDUCATION
ISSUES AND THE KIND OF THE DAY
TO DAY BUSINESS AND THIS FEELS
LIKE SOMETHING THAT'S REALLY
FAR AWAY- BOTH FOR THE FOLKS
RUNNING CITY GOVERNMENT AND
COUNTY GOVERNMENTS AND IN MANY
CASES BUT ALSO FOR THE CITIZENS
AND DON'T ARE THERE NOT KINDA
CLAMORING FOR ACTION ON THIS
YET ESPECIALLY WHEN THOSE
ACTIONS ARE GOING TO BE KIND
OF. COULD BE REALLY DIFFICULT
DECISIONS IT FEELS LIKE THIS
ISN'T A HIGH PRIORITY YET FOR
THEM. AND THEN THE FINAL
CHALLENGE WE HEARD ABOUT IS.
REGULATORY BARRIERS REALLY THAT
IF. FOLKS ARE READY TO TRIED
DOING SOME OF THESE PROJECTS
ARE ARE ENVIRONMENTAL
PERMITTING SYSTEM AGENCIES THEY
HAVE TO GO TO AREN'T REALLY SET
UP YET TO KIND OF KNOW HOW TO
GRAPPLE WITH THESE. KINDS OF
PROJECTS THERE USED TO
EVALUATING THE EFFECTS OF.
BUILDING A NEW HOTEL ALONG THE
COAST NOT BUILDING A LIVING
SHORELINE PROJECT ALONG THE
COAST AND SO WE NEED TO MAKE
SOME ADJUSTMENTS ABOUT- THE
PROCESS IS IT'S JUST TAKING TOO
LONG RIGHT NOW TO TRY AND GET
SOME OF THESE PROJECTS DONE. SO
WHAT DO WE RECOMMEND THAT YOU
ALL DO ABOUT THIS- WE HAVE-
TWELVE RECOMMENDATIONS IN OUR
REPORT SUMMER IS THE FACT. THIS
ONE INJURED. I'M AND IN FOR.
SOMEONE INDEED WHEN ALL OF
THEM. ANSWER QUESTIONS. THE
FIRST CATEGORY IS A REACHED
SCALE ADAPTATION AND WE BREAK
DOWN. SILOS AND HELP. LOCAL
THERE TO I AM A SOME OF SHOES
THAT ARE TO BE THE FACT THAT
TOGETHER AND I THINK YOU'LL
HEAR A LOT ABOUT WHAT THE
PROGRESS THAT HAS BEEN MADE
HERE IN THE BAY ON SOME OF
THESE ISSUES SO SPECIFICALLY
WERE RECOMMENDING THAT THE
STATE PROVIDE FUNDING. TO HELP
HIRE SOME STAFF FOR REGIONAL
COLLABORATIVE GROUPS TO SET UP
A STRUCTURE TO DEVELOP PLANNING
AND PLANS FOR IS SOME CROSS
REGIONAL PLANS AND- THEN
PROVIDE MONEY TO IMPLEMENT SOME
OF THE PROJECTS THAT ARE
ADDRESSED IN THOSE PLANS. I'M
THE SECOND CATEGORY
RECOMMENDATIONS EVEN IF WE SOME
OF THIS GREAT REGIONAL WORK
DOESN'T IN THE IN VITRO STUDIES
ZINC NASAL. SO NEED TO
UNDERTAKE JACKSON PLANNING I'M
SORRY SO I THINK THIS NEEDS TO
CONTINUE FOCUSING SUPPORTING
THAT WELL. SO FAR FUNDING FOR
OUR PLAN IN. TECH WE RECOMMEND
THIS PROJECT SPEAK IF I'M-
SPECIFIC ABOUT WHAT THE STATE
IS PUTTING MONEY INTO SO THAT
THE STATE IS REALLY YIELDING
BENEFITS FROM IT- AND THAT IT'S
APPROPRIATE FOR PUBLIC DOLLARS
OF THAT REALLY FOCUS ON
WIDESPREAD PUBLIC BENEFITS-
NATURAL RESOURCES AND THEN ALSO
TESTING OUT SOME STRATEGIES
THAT'S IN A PERFECTLY.
APPROPRIATE USE OF STATE
FUNDING WHAT CAN WE LEARN AND
HOW CAN WE SHARE THAT ACROSS
THE STATE. AND IN ORDER TO SHOW
THAT WE'RE GOING TO NEED TO
MAKE SURE WE HAVE MONITORING
AND INFORMATION SHARING AS WELL.
THE THIRD CATEGORY AGAIN. THANK
YOU FOR THE STATE PROVIDING FOR
ME ASSISTANCE AND SUPPORT.
TYPICALLY WERE WRECKED INNINGS
NAPA AT THE BAD ATTITUDE SEND
TEXT PLEASE BEAR WITH SOME.
TOYS LOCATION AS SOME REGIONALS
AFTER THIS IS RIGHT RESPOND TO
WHAT WE'VE OVER NO CAN I NEED
SOMEBODY TO CALL A WEBSITE IS
NOT GOOD ENOUGH. NEEDS TO CALL
ALL UP TALK THROUGH THE ISSUES
WITH ME CONNECT YOU WITH THE L.
WHO HAS WORKED ON THIS TWO WAY
AND LEARN FROM THEM I THINK
THAT- IMPORT ROLE THE STATE AS
WELL AS DEVELOPING INTO AND
HELPING- ADDRESS OF THESE THE
TOP EIGHT. ROADBLOCKS AND THEN
THE FINAL CATEGORY. IS REALLY
FOCUSING ON THIS PUBLIC
AWARENESS ISSUE SO WE RECOMMEND
PUTTING IT SEC I'M- IT WILL
CAMPAIGN TO CREASE LOOK AWAY S.
ENSURE THERE'S BROUGHT OUT SH
FOR STATE FUNDED PROGRAM IS-
THEN WE ALSO RECOMMEND THE
STATE ADOPT. REQUIRE FOR REAL
THE DISCLOSURES ARE ON FLOODING
FOR SEA LEVEL RISE COMPARABLE
TO WHAT WE HAVE FOR EARTHQUAKES
OR- FIRES OR OTHER KINDS OF
FLOODING THERE'S ACTUALLY MORE
CERTAINTY ABOUT SEA LEVEL RISE
THAN THERE IS ABOUT EARTHQUAKES
SO WE THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE
PUBLIC POLICY THAT THAT BE
INCLUDED IN INFORMATION THAT
OUR IS PROVIDED AS PART OF.
THAT TRANSACTIONS. SO IN TERMS
OF NEXT STEPS WHAT WE'RE DOING
HERE RIGHT TODAY IS ONE OF
THOSE NEXT STEPS- IN TRYING TO
INCREASE. AWARENESS OVERSIGHT
INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS YOU HAVE.
THE CIVIC PLEDGE OF PIECES OF
LEGISLATION THAT YOU'RE RIGHT
DISPOSABLE BUT AT TEN SHARP
CLIMATE AND TO THE OLDER.
ACTION THEY DEPART DO YOU HAVE
ACTUALLY BUT OF COURSE AT YOUR
FINGER TO TRY AND ADDRESS SOME
OF THESE ISSUES EVEN FEEL A LOT
OF THE WORK NEEDS TO BE DONE
LOCAL WILL YOU TOOL AS WELL.
AND HOW ARE. IN FINE WE CLOSE
FOR AN EMAIL POSTED WHICH IS
STATE IF WE DO ALL OF THE BUT
WE ARE HERE WE WENT DONE. I'M
HEARD BUT THROUGHOUT THE
RESEARCH. OF ISSUES THAT ARE
GOING TO LIMIT THE HER IN THAT
ARE BEYOND THE SCOPE OF WORK
DID IN. HERE I'M. OR SEEN IN
BEARS. ISN'T IT EARNS MARKETS
HAPPEN AN INCH IS OF. IT IS OUT
OF IT THAT STILL HOME RISEN
BUSINESS OWNERS THEY ARE. A LOT
OF GOING INTO WHEN THE TIDE
BEING AND LINE OF PUBLIC TRUST
AND **** TO MOVE AND DID IT IN
NEWS. I MEAN THERE'S A LOT OF.
THINGS OUT THERE THAT WILL
BEFORE HE WAS THE LEGISLATURE.
THINKING WHERE AND HOW WE BILL
YEAH THESE ARE LOT OF THAT
AGAIN ARE WE'VE WE'VE THIS AS A
FIRST STEP TRYING TO SUPPORT
LOCAL PLANNING BUT THE ISSUES
ARE ARE BEING AND LOOMING AS
WELL. SO WITH THAT HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS ALL OUR
WORK IS ALWAYS ON OUR WEBSITE
AND I'M- THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
HAVING US TODAY. ANY QUESTIONS
FOR OUR PANEL. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR THANK YOU RACHEL FOR THE
PRESENTATION AND FOR SETTING
THAT SETTING THE TABLE FOR US.
THE GOVERNOR HAS TALKED ABOUT A
FIVE BILLION DOLLAR BOND IN THE
BUDGET. OF THE SENATE AS WELL
AS BEING. TOO SHORT OF A FIVE
BILLION THE ASSEMBLY IS
COMPILING IS PROPOSAL FOR BOND
FINANCING TO DEAL WITH CLIMATE
RESILIENCY. AND SOMETHING THAT
CONTEMPLATES THE MAGNITUDE OF
THE CHALLENGE WE HAVE. YOUR THE
FISCAL PURSE I WANTED TO JUST
ASK YOU IF THERE IS A BUDGET
REASON WHY WE OUT OF OURSELVES
TO FIVE BILLION DOLLARS WE HAVE
A FIFTEEN BILLION DOLLAR. BOND
ON THE MARCH BALLOT FOR
EDUCATION WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
SOMETHING AT THE FIVE BILLION
DOLLAR LEVEL FOR SOMETHING THAT
IS IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD OF FIFTY
TO A HUNDRED TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY BILLION DOLLAR-
CHALLENGE. IS THERE A IS THERE
BUDGET REASON WHY WE OUGHT TO
LIMIT OURSELVES- AT THIS TIME.
CAN YOU SPEAK TO THE BONDED
INDEBTEDNESS- STATUS OF OUR
BONDED INDEBTEDNESS NOW IN
CALIFORNIA AND- SORT OF WHERE
WE ARE HISTORICALLY WITH REGARD
TO BONDED INDEBTEDNESS AND IS
THERE A CONCERN ABOUT THE
BROADER ECONOMY WHERE A GROWTH
PERIOD THE RECESSION IS NOT
UPON US YET BUT JUST SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT WE OUGHT TO BE
CONSIDERING ONE WERE ACTUALLY
CRAFTING A PROPOSAL THAT MIGHT
GO BEFORE THE VOTERS. SURE
YEAH. THERE'S NO RIGHT NUMBER
FOR A BOND- AND WE WOULDN'T
EVEN AS YOUR FISCAL VISORS
WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO TELL YOU
WHAT THE RIGHT NUMBER IS BUT I
THINK THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
TRADE OFF SOME OF THE
CONSIDERATIONS WE WOULD SUGGEST
THINKING ABOUT OR WHAT DO YOU
ASSESSES THE NEED. RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE THEY BELIEVE THE
BENEFIT OF BONDS AS IT PROVIDES
AN INFLUX OF FUNDING OF
IMMEDIATELY FOR NEAR TERM.
CAPITAL PROJECTS- TO TRADE OFF
WITH BOND IS THAT THEN YOU'RE
PAYING FOR IT FOR QUITE AWHILE
YOU KNOW FOR USUALLY THIRTY TO
FORTY YEARS. AND I'M AND YOU'RE
PAYING MORE BECAUSE YOU'RE
PAYING INTEREST. AND THOSE OUT
YOUR COSTS ARE NON NEGOTIABLE
THEIR COMMITMENTS ITS FIRST
CALL AND THE GENERAL FUND EVERY
YEAR- SO RIGHT NOW WE'RE
SPENDING ABOUT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR OUT OF THE
GENERAL FUND ON DEBT FOR
PREVIOUS. ONES ABOUT ONE IN
LITTLE OR ONE MILLION AND FOR
NOW RESOURCE RELATED BONDS
HISTORICALLY THAT'S A PRETTY
LOW PERCENTAGE OF GENERAL FUND
IT'S ABOUT 4% OF OUR ANNUAL
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURES RIGHT
NOW FOR BOND AT. THAT'S FOR.
REASONS ONE IS WE HAVE A VERY
HEALTHY GENERAL RIGHT NOW HIS
STORE. SO FOR AS LOW BECAUSE
OUR IS ONE OF THOSE REASONS. SO
I THINK WE WOULD ADVISE WHEN
YOU THINK ABOUT BONDS IS NOT
FREE MANY- IT DOES HAVE KIND OF.
GENERATIONAL IMPACTS IN TERMS
OF PAYING IT OFF AS WELL AS-
THE BENEFITS- SO YOU COULD ALSO
THINK ABOUT A COMBINATION OF
SOME BONDS- AMOUNT TO. THAT YOU
FOR ON WHICH YOU WILL HAVE TO
PAY THAT DEBT BUT ALSO WE
BECAUSE WE DO HAVE A HEALTHY
GENERAL FUND RIGHT NOW YOU
COULD ALSO THINK ABOUT SOME PAY
AS YOU GO. AND SOME. UP FRONT
GENERAL FUND COSTS THAT. I'M
DEBT AND PERHAPS THE STATE IS
BETTER POSITION TO ALL FOR NOW.
IT DOESN'T COMMIT ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES IN THE FUTURE WHEN
THE STATE MIGHT NOT BE AS ABLE
TO AFFORD AN. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR OF. FRUIT AND
FOR THE WORK OF THE LA WAS
OFTEN THE REPORT OF A YOUR
LYING IN THE SONG WHICH IS THAT
AND WITH THE SIX IS IN THE
TWELVE DAYS SOME. KIND OF PHONE
WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT I MEAN
THEY'RE SO MANY FOR. I GUESS
THE QUESTION COMES TO MY FOR ME
IS WHERE DO WE BE. WHAT WOULD
BE. THE FIRST SECOND THIRD
THING TO ME A NUMBER OF THE
STATE AND PROBABLY THE MOST
OBVIOUS TO ME IS THE ONE THAT-
MACHINE. IS NOT A PRIORITY
THOUGH IT'S THE EDUCATION AND
KIND OF WHAT WE'RE DOING TODAY
WITH THE TIRES LEADERSHIP- BUT-
WHERE WOULD IS THERE A BENEFIT
IN ORDER THAT WE SHOULD FOLLOW.
YEAH I THINK WE WOULD SUGGEST
THAT PLANNING. YOU KNOW MANY
FOR PLANNING NEEDS TO COME
BEFORE PROJECTS AND- SO SOME OF
THAT PLANNING AND THEN SETTING
UP SOME OF THESE REGIONAL
PARTNERSHIPS IS ALSO KIND OF A
FIRST LINE- ACTIVITY. COMMAND
PROVIDING SOME SOME PRETTY
MODEST AMOUNT OF FUNDING FOR.
FIRST OF STAFF IN CREATING
REGIONAL CLUB AROUND THE STATE-
TO START THAT. YOU KNOW I THINK
ONE OF THE POINTS WE TRY TO
MAKE IS WE NEED TO START DOING
SOME PROJECTS AND SOME PILOT
PROJECTS IN PARTICULAR TO LEARN
BUT- WE DON'T WANT WE DON'T
WANT TO INFUSE SO MUCH FUNDING
IMMEDIATELY. IT'S KIND OF GOOD
PROJECTS ARE READY TO GO AND
THE PLANNING IS AN IN PLACE
BECAUSE WE DO NEED TO BE
STRATEGIC AND HAVE A
COORDINATED APPROACH AND WE
CAN'T DO THAT UNLESS WE HAVE
THE I. RELATIONSHIP PARTNERSHIP
SET UP TO BEGAN- THINKING ABOUT
THINGS ON A REGIONAL BASIS.
MICHAEL ACTUALLY ABOUT EXACTLY
THAT WOULD TAX AND FROM WHAT
YOU TEENS THE ONE OVER THERE
ARE DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES AND
THAT ALREADY WITH CERTAIN PILOT
PROJECTS THAT COULD BE FUNDED-
YEAH WE WERE. FORTUNATE TO BE
IN GOOD BUDGETARY TIMES AND
WE'RE ALL ABOUT ONE TIME
SPENDING WE DON'T WANT TO LOCK
IN TOO MUCH SPENDING IS WE
DON'T KNOW HOW LONG THE GOOD
TIMES ALAS RIGHT. ARE THERE
PROJECTS ACROSS THE STATE THAT
YOU SEEN THE THAT ARE CLOSE TO
SHOVEL READY- THAT THE STATE
COULD AND THE TO START TESTING
TO SEE DIFFERENT CONCEPTS I
THINK I THINK THERE ARE- AND IN
FACT THERE WAS ONE IN IN
ENCINITAS IN THE CHAIRS
DISTRICT BUT THAT IS KIND OF
ONE OF THE ONES THAT'S HELD UP.
OF A LIVING SHORELINE PROJECT
THAT. THEN I'M SURE. SHARE
COULD SPEAK TO BETTER ME BUT-
YES AND I THINK THE COASTAL
CONSERVANCY THE STATE COASTAL
CONSERVANCY IS OUR AGENCY THAT
HAS. TYPICALLY BEEN A CONDUIT
BY WHICH WE HAVE FUNDED
PROJECTS THROUGH THE STATE AND
THEY'VE KIND OF GOT THEIR
FINGER ON THE PULSE. THEY MAY
NEED TO BE SOME ADDITIONAL
FUNDING ON PLANNING JUST TO DO
THAT. HAVE ENVIRONMENTAL PLANS
AND PERMITTING THAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE FOR THOSE PROJECTS- WHICH-
HASN'T BEEN A LOT OF STATE
FUNDING FOR WE'VE- BEEN
PROVIDING FUNDING FOR THINGS
LIKE FROM ABILITY ASSESSMENTS
AND CONNECT AT FIRST BUT THERE
IS A- THERE IS A GAP. ON THAT-
NEXT SEVERAL. FOR LANDING
SPECIFIC PROJECTS BEFORE YOU
ARE READY TO DO THE ACTUAL ALL
I'M GRANTING FOR IT BUT BUT YES
I THINK IN ANSWER TO YOUR
QUESTION WE ARE STARTING AND
THERE WERE PROBABLY BE MORE IF
FOLKS KNOW THAT THERE MIGHT BE
MONEY AVAILABLE FOR IT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR THE VERY
INFORMATIVE PANEL- WE ARE
RUNNING SLIGHTLY BEHIND SO. YOU
DON'T HAVE TO USE IT TIRED OF A
MINUTES ALLOTTED TO YOU. AND
YOU'RE A LARGE PIZZA ALSO IS
ASSEMBLY AREA SEE WILL RISE
CHALLENGES FROM HEARING FROM A
LOCAL GOVERNMENT. ONLY WITH
SUPERVISOR DAVID I AM FROM SAN
MATTEO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. MAYOR CATHERINE MY
HAN BORDER I HOPE I PRONOUNCE
THAT CORRECTLY AND CITY MANAGER
JEFF. MONATE AT FROM THE CITY
OF FOSTER CITY SO THANK YOU FOR
HAVING US HERE. I THINK WHAT
WE'LL JUST KIND OF JUST ROTATED
IN. SO START WITH YOU GUYS AND
THEN WE'LL GO ON TO OUR NEXT
PANELIST SO. YOU EACH KEEP IT
SAYS SEVEN MINUTES ARE UNDER
THAT WOULD BE PERFECT THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON THIS ANY
MEMBERS IN CENTER HELLO. MY
NAME'S DAVE PINE IT FROM THE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS. I
MUCH APPRECIATE YOU CONVENING
THIS HEARING. I READ A THAT.
THE TEMPERATURE REQUISITE MAN
IN IN ANTARCTICA IT'S A SIXTY
FIVE DEGREES ON ANTARCTICA
PENINSULA TODAY HAVE JUST EVER
SO THAT WATER IS HEADING
HEADING OUR WAY I WANTED TO
GIVE YOU A TASTE FOR. THE
CHALLENGES WE FACE HERE IN SAN
MATEO COUNTY AND THE WORK
THAT'S UNDER WAY- TO ADDRESS
THESE CHALLENGES. WE'VE HEARD A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT- THE FUTURE
PROJECTIONS I TYPICALLY TELL
PEOPLE THAT THERE ARE YOUNG
CHILDREN TODAY THAT WILL SEE
THE PAY RISE BY FEET AND THEIR
TIME NO QUESTION ABOUT IT. ON A
COURTESY COULD BE MUCH WORSE
DEPENDING ON HOW GLACIERS IF.
BOB THE COUNTY SAN MATTEO HAS
ENGAGED IN THIS ISSUE FOR ABOUT
FIVE YEARS OR MORE NOW THE
FIRST THING WE DID WAS TO
COMPLETE AN- BILLION CYCLE
PEDIC VULNERABILITY ASSESSMENT.
TO LOOK AT THE EXPOSURE ON ONLY
ON OUR MUTUAL BUT ALSO ON OUR-
ON OUR COAST SIDE. AND AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN SAID-
THE DATE IS NOT TO INCREASING
WELL WE LOOK TO DO SAYS. NO ONE
OF COURSE IS PATIENTS ALL
RIGHTS. THAT ARE THERE ARE.
GREAT TO READ. IF WE A SO
CALLED PERSON ARM WE WILL SEE
FLOODING BUT WHEN YOU FINALLY
SEALEVEL RISE. IT'S MUCH MORE
SEVERE- YOUR STATE IS ONE OF
OUR- BILL WILSHIRE COURSE
DEBATE OR IF YOU LOOK AT HIS
MOUTH WHERE A NUMBER WAS WE
USED OF TOP TEN A WEAPON.
COURSE LONGER AND- TENSION FOR
THE DOLLAR IN THAT IT REALLY
UNDER THE PEOPLE. SO WE THOUGHT
THIS CHALLENGE WE MOVE BEYOND
CECIL ACT NOW THAT'S THE THANK
WATER WORK ANALYSTS MEN BUT WE
NEED TO TAKE AT TEN AM TO STOP
NOW. REALLY RESTRICT. ACT COM
LIVE WITH THE WATER WE WILL
TAKE OUR DATA PRIMARILY. DIED
ABOUT BIG ABOUT THE COASTAL
TOWN TO SWEAR COMMENTATING IN
REAL. SEC I LOG THIS MAP I WILL
GO WHERE EVERYTHING WAS WRONG
MANY PRODUCTS AND WE HAVE UNDER
WHAT. NG STAY AND IN SOME THIS
OF ACTUALLY STRUCTURE DATE.
THING IS LARA COME IN OUR SO
WHAT THE MOST EXPOSED. THE I
WOULD TO CONTAIN WE'RE ALL.
COUNTY THINKING ABOUT AND HAS
THE MOST WAY. CUP BUT THANKS.
IS THE TO SEPARATE SALMON
COUNTY FROM SANTA NINE ANY
EIGHT IN EL NINO AND CALL FORTY
MILLION AS A DATE WHICH- AND IT
TOOK A LONG TIME. I WOULD
COMPLETED A SEVENTIES MILLION
DOLLAR PROJECT THAT WILL BY. IN
IN A- WARM UP THE GARAGE BY THE
ISSUE GUN IN THE STATE. I'M
THERE PROP CALL ME FOR BAY.
NINE OH NATION LET AND-
DURATION FROM OUT TO THE WITH.
BORDER CORSA STRAP THE BOOK WE
IS WE ARE. BRING ABOUT A STUDY
ON REAL PROJECT TO MOVE. ABOUT
THEIR- SIX MILLION PROJECT
MENDEZ EFFORT BEING INTO THE-
YOU'LL HEAR MORE JEFF IS HERE
I'M UP IN THE MILLION DOLLARS
THE DRESS BUILDING. OFTENTIMES
IS. EVERYONE SQUARE YEAH. BACK
TO A GREAT BAND INVENTOR POP
TIONS ARE ARE TO BUY FLOOD OF
IRAQ'S WE HAVE AREA WITH CITY
CALLED A FRANK NOW WHICH
STRIDES IN ALMOST ANY SPORT
EVENT. AND HAS FOR DECADES AND
WE'VE COME UP WITH AN APPROACH
TO TRY TO ADDRESS THAT-
COLLABORATING WITH REDWOOD CITY
AND OTHERS WHICH I SPEAK TO AT
THE END. ANOTHER KEY FACTOR I
JUST WANNA SMACK MOMENT ON ALL
UP AND WHEN IT TOO. THE SHORE
THANK. FOR YOUR THE ROCK WE
SOMETHING TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
ACRES OF VINES. HERE THE BAY UP
IN THE GOAL OF RESTORING DOUBT.
UNDER AMAZING BECAUSE IT IS A
QUESTION. AND HE SAYS AND BY
STATE. SO THERE IS A GROUP OF
THE SAME FISCAL STRAIGHT TOWARD
WHICH I CARE AND BECAUSE OF THE
GENEROSITY OF THE- NIGHT COUNTY.
HARPER CONTACT PLACE ALL NINE
PASSED WITH OVER 60% OF THE
VOTE COUPLE HISTORIC VOTE I'M
THE PEOPLE THIS WEEK THE BANK
ONE EVEN THE- THIS FOR THE- I.
HAVE ABOUT FIVE MILLION OVER
TWO YEARS TO INVEST IN WHEN
RESTORATION. CUP POINTS STAMP
AS ON. THERE'S ALWAYS SONOMA
URGENCY AND IS THIS BAR IN
FUTURE. COMES TWENTY IT IS
URGENT BECAUSE AS MANY IS THAT
WE CAN RESTORE IT DON'T STAB
WORKS BY TWENTY THIRTY WILL
LOSE THE OPPORTUNITY IS SCIENCE
SHOWS IS THAT THESE- WETLANDS
AND CAN ACTUALLY TO SOME
DEGREE. UGH RESPOND TO GROW-
WITH SEA LEVEL RISE TO THE
COLLECTION OF SEDIMENT SO WE
REALLY ASKED WE DO HAVE
EMERGENCY ON THESE WETLAND
RESTORATIONS AND WE HAVE
EVERYTHING IN PLACE TO MOVE
FORWARD MUCH MORE RAPIDLY WE
HAVE THE RESTORATION AUTHORITY.
WE HAVE- WE'VE RECENTLY PUT IN
PLACE SOMETHING CALLED THE- THE
REST OF THE BAY RESTORATION
REGULATORY INTEGRATION TEAM
QUITE A MOUTHFUL BUT IT'S AN
EFFORT TO BRING REGULATORS
TOGETHER SO WE GET THESE THINGS
PERMITTED FASTER IS EVEN THOUGH
IT'S LIKE. YOU KNOW- YOU KNOW
THESE THINGS CAN BE REMARKABLY
BOGGED DOWN WITH PERMITS SO WE
WE'VE WE'VE SOLVING FOR THAT
PROBLEM. WE HAVE PLANS WE HAVE
SCIENCE- SO THIS NEXT TEN YEARS
KEY PADS DISCUSSIONS- WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN SAYS
CENTER HILL OF. THE ROLE THE
RESILIENCY BOND. AND PERHAPS.
IN THE LECTURE FUNDING WE HAVE
A PROJECT IN THE SOUTH. THE
RAVENS WOULD PINE PART OF THE
SPACE ON REST. BECAUSE
RESTAURANT PROJECT THE CIVIC
CENTER MAKE. ON THE COAST VERY
DIFFERENT SITUATION VERY HERE
COASTAL EROSION. THIS WORKS
THIS A FULL. WELL FOR HOW MANY.
IS THIS A- AWESOME HAVE BEEN
RUNNING FOR LONG TIME MUCH OF
THAT IS TO RIGHT NOW TO SEE A
RISE YOUR EYES COMPOUND THE. WE
HAVE A IS THAT HE NEEDS OUR ON
THE GO STE. THERE CHALLENGE.
THE OCEAN. TO BE STRONG FOR.
AND IT IS ABOUT WHAT BE
PROTECTED WAY CAN'T. ACTION OF
ARMOR CAN CAUSE ELSEWHERE THE
CARD. TELL ME CLOSE WITH WHAT I.
VERY GOOD ABOUT THANK FOR IS A
MODEL FOR A PLACES STATE.
MATTEO COUNTY LIES IN THE
GRAVITY OF THIS. ALL TWENTY
CITY EVERY OF THEM EVEN THE
FIVE TO A DON'T TOUCH THAT OR
THE BAY WE'VE COME TO GET TO
FORM THE SAN MATEO COUNTY FLOOD
AND SEE OF ALL RISE RESILIENCY
DISTRICT ALL THESE TWENTY
CITIES ARE PAYING FUNDS INTO
THE ENTITY IN ADDITION TO THE
COUNTY OF SAN MATTEO. WE FORMA
SANITY WITH THE HELP OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN TUESDAY
LEGISLATION TO ONE BUILD
EXPERTISE IS WE HAVE TO DEAL
WITH THIS ISSUE FOR THE LONG
RUN. I'M TO WE CAN'T DEAL WITH
IT CITY BY CITY SO WE'RE
BRINGING THE CITIES TO GET
THROUGH THIS DISTRICT MEANT
THREE ULTIMATELY NOW WE HAVE TO
COMPETE FOR FINDING AT THE
FEDERAL STATE LEVEL AND WE
WOULD DO THAT WITH WITH MORE
UNIFIED VOICE. SO THIS
ORGANIZATION LEGAL AND WE THINK
IT CAN BE GUIDE OUR IN THE
AHEAD THIS IS SOME OF THE-
DETAILS ON HOW WE PUT IT
TOGETHER WHICH- YOU CAN.
ACTUALLY BUT I'M I'M OUT OF THE
FACT THAT ARE OUR OUR MONEY.
PAST TOGETHER THIS WAY. IS
THIS. AT THE TERM. WITH THIS
IT'S NOT GOING TO GO AWAY AND
WE'RE A BETTER WE'RE GONNA PACK
BUT THAT ON. THANK YOU AND THEN
WE'LL MOVE ON TO OUR WE CAN
HAVE THE PANELISTS HOLDER
QUESTIONS THE END. CATHERINE
MANN- MAINBOARD IS THAT CORRECT
MY- MOM FOR YES THANK YOU AND
THE CITY MANAGER JEFF MY NAME.
THANK YOU. SO WE'RE HAPPY TO BE
HOSTING THE STATE ASSEMBLY
SELECT COMMITTEE ON SEA LEVEL
RISE. AND WE WELCOME ALL OF YOU
TO FOSTER CITY. A MEASURE NO
WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF RISING
RAISING OUR LEVEES TO ADDRESS
SEA LEVEL RISE STEARNS AND WAVE
OVERTOPPING ISSUES. THIS IS
CERTAINLY THE MOST IMPORTANT
PROJECT FOR FOSTER CITY TO
PROTECT OUR RESIDENTS AND
BUSINESSES. FROM DAMAGE TO THEM
AND THEIR PROPERTIES FROM
POSSIBLE FLOODING DUE TO SEA
LEVEL RISE. BUDGET IS FUNDED
THROUGH A NINETY MILLION DOLLAR
BOND MEASURE PAID FOR BY FOSTER
CITY PROPERTY OWNERS BOTH
RESIDENTIAL AND COMMERCIAL. ARE
PUNISHED US WITH OVER ONE
APPROVED BECAUSE WE UNDER ANY.
OUR WE FORTY WHICH TO SEE IT
RIGHT NOW WE DO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS. WHERE THE CITY THE
BAY AREA THE TOP POSITION ARE
ARE PRETTY RESERVE NUMBER OF AN
IBM MEANT. THERE IS WITH THE
HELP OF YOU KNOW AGENCIES.
DON'T OUR TAX BE ASSIDUOUS
TOMORROW THANK STRIPS I WANT
FOR OUR MIND AS A PART OF A
LATENCY. I KNOW ANSWER IT THAT
IS WE RECEIVED THROUGH THE
ENDING PROCESS TOOK ABOUT A
YEAR. PAYS THE HURDLES TO LATE.
DELAYED WE DON'T THE PROJECT
BECAUSE LONGER THANKS TO RE
PERMIT THE GREAT COST STRUCTURE.
WE MAY MAKE ANOTHER SUGGESTION
IN ST MEANING THE PERMITTING
PROCESS THE TICKET CONSIDER
ATION WITH NO MENTION FOR YOU.
NOW I'M GONNA PASS IT UP TO
ARES MANAGE MENT TO DESCRIBE
THE PROJECT MORE DETAIL AND
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENDANCE. THANK YOU. I'LL BE
PROVIDING A HISTORY OF THE
PROJECT DESIGN OVERVIEW AND
THEN A TIME LINE OF NEXT STEPS.
TO THE AREA IN RED IN THE SLIDE
TO THE RIGHT IN AND OUT
ACTUALLY TO THE LEFT AS WELL
SHOW THE ALIGNMENT OF OUR
CURRENT LEVY IT'S ABOUT AN
EIGHT MILE STRETCH. FRONT ALONG
THE WALL CURRENT. SOUTH OF THIS
DO WE HAVE SALUTE. TO GIVE YOU
SOME BACKGROUND DURING THIS
PROJECT IN TWENTY FOURTEEN IS
WHEN I STARTED AS THE PUBLIC
CORRECT. FIRST MY INBOX WAS A
FROM. THE FEET LETTERS AS THE
RAISE YOUR LEVY. ENOUGH SO ON
THE ENTIRE THE STORY. IS NEVER
BEEN A ZONE. ABOUT STRESS-
BELOW THAT IMMEDIATELY HE ALSO
CITED WRETCH TO. LEARN TO
ASSIST A- PIECE OF THIS NINE.
WE STARTED WORKING BASIS IT IS
UP TO WORK WITH CONSULT HIM AS
WELL BALLOT THE STAFF. YOU CAN
CHECK THE- TODD NOW THIS WAS
CORRECT AND AS A RESULT WE DO
THE COUNCIL NOT TO CHALLENGE
THE MATH TIME IN TWENTY FIFTEEN
WE ASKED FOR HIM OF COURSE THE
COLLUSION MAPPING DESIGNATION
AND WHAT THAT ALLOWS US TO DO
IS STAY OUT OF THE FLOOD ZONE
ALL PROPERTY OWNERS WOULD STAY
OUT OF THE FLOOD ZONE PROVIDED
THAT WE SHOW PROGRESS WITH THE
PROJECT AT ANY TIME FEE LOOK AT
A PLACE TO SIT IN THE FLOOD
ZONE. IN TWENTY SWEEP WE
STARTED PROGRESSING WITH DESIGN
AND IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE HAD
OUR ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT REPORT
CERTIFIED. IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
ONCE WE WERE ABLE TO AS WE GOT
FURTHER ALONG WITH DESIGN AND
WE WERE ABLE TO COME UP WITH A-
REASONABLE COST ESTIMATE. IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE HAD A BALLOT
MEASURE AND IN JUNE OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THAT SUCCESSFULLY
PASSED WITH AN 81% APPROVAL. IN
TWENTY NINETEEN- WILL WE BE WE
CONTINUED WITH DESIGN. AND WE
INITIATED THE PERMIT PROCESS
TOWARDS THE END OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN BEGINNING OF TWENTY
NINETEEN. ON JANUARY SEVENTH.
OF THIS YEAR WE RECEIVED A
LITTLE BIT OF A LATE CHRISTMAS
PRESENT AND WE GOT OUR FINAL
PERMIT. SO WE'RE VERY HAPPY
ABOUT THAT. WE ANTICIPATE A
BEGINNING CONSTRUCTION RIGHT
AROUND TWENTY TWENTY WITH
ENDING CONSTRUCTION IS A THREE
YEAR CONSTRUCTION PERIOD
DEALING WITH- TIMES
ENVIRONMENTAL CONSTRAINTS. AND
DEALING WITH WHEN YOU CAN
CONDUCT CONSTRUCTION SO WE'RE
LOOKING AT A THREE YEAR
CONSTRUCTION PERIOD. AND SO
BEGINNING IN JULY OF TWENTY
TWENTY AND ENDING IN TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. SO THIS LIGHT
HERE SHOWS WHAT. WHAT I DESIGN
IS HOW HOW WE NEED TO GO IF YOU
SEE THE A SCALE I'M CONCERT WAS
ONE TWO AND FOUR AND WE'LL TAKE
A LOOK AT WHAT FIRST. ONE IS
GROUP. TO THE EGGS TING OUT
PATIENTS THIRTEEN. AND THE
HEIGHT WE RAISE THE LEVEL WAS.
OFF SEE TRACK THOSE TO IN THE
ELEVATE OUR LEAD TO A- AREA YOU
GO TO SHOULDN'T FIVE IT IS OUR
WAY ACTION THERE. WE ARE REYES.
TO NAP BEAT. THE TO SUBSTANCE
IN THE LISTING A PATIENT TWELVE
THIRTY AND WE RAISE IT THIRTY
AND I HE- IS AT TO HAVE LESS
DAY THAT. BUDGET I AM SEVERAL
OF IT IS BASED. YOUR CITY THE
UNLESS IT'S THE ONE THAT VERY
TOP LEFT AND THAT IS YOU'LL SEE
AN FOUND IS THE EXIST THREE AND
THIS IS A SECTION. YOU HAVE TO
RUN THE LETTER B. AS AS BILL
THIS. DOWN HI. TO EXIST STE. SO
HELLO. AND WE HI SHE ALL WHICH
OPPOSES TO WHICH PILOT SOUNDS
RAISE THE TOWARDS LAND BIRDS.
AND TEAR DOWN TO EXISTING
GOVERNMENT AND THEN PENSION
PLAN UNDER NEW THE NINE BREAK
THE NET SO WHERE WE HAVE TOLD
THE WALLS WE TO TIE INTO THIS
STRUCK. IT IS AREAS WE CONVERT
FLOOD BALLS SO TOTAL YOU HAVE
TWENTY TO THE THREE HUNDRED
FEET HIGH. BUT FIVE THOUSAND
FOUR. LEVY FOR A FEE OF FLOOD
WILL. SO THE NEXT HERE JUST
DOES SHE DO UP I'M- BIG DOWN UP
SO OUR OUR LEVEE IMPROVEMENT
ALSO EIGHT WITH IS. SET TO TIE
BAY AREA IT RB TRAIL SYSTEM.
THE DISTINGUISHED TRIP WELL AS
OUT TEN FEET TO TWENTY TWELVE
FEEL NOW. AND WITH THE TEMPO IT
ACTUALLY OF THE CITY WIDE. SO
YOU'LL SEE THE STATE OF UP
WHICH TWELVE. ENSURE THEN THE
PATRIOT SO USE THIS PILE WALL
WE THE RIGHT IS THE LET.
THURSDAY BUT THIS LOW THE WILL
BE TEAM WHY WOULD PROVIDE THIS
RATIO INCREASE SAFETY. BEATS
CREATION BETWEEN BY IN PUT. SO
THIS IS JUST A CROSS SECTION
WHERE WE HAVE TO MEET EIGHT
EIGHTY EIGHT ARKANSAS
DISABILITIES ACT REQUIREMENTS
THIS IS ON A BEACH PARTY PART
AB LANES MORRELL AVENUE SO
STREET- WE HAVE TO HOLD THE A
TEST IMPROVEMENTS AT THOSE ARE
PART OF OUR DESIGN. FAR AS
FINANCING GOES. AS A BALLOT
MEASURE IT'S ESTIMATED NINE
BILLION DOLLARS. IS FINANCING
100% OF THE COST. AND AS WELL
AS A CONTRIBUTION FROM THE CITY
FROM THE GENERAL FUND. AND AS I
MENTION ONE MORE MINUTE
THINKING ONE MORE MINUTE THIS
IS THE LAST FLIGHT. PERFECT SO-
CURRENTLY WE WORE THE
CONSTRUCTION MANAGEMENT CON
WHICH HOUSES TO OCCUR THE BILL
THE REVIEW WAS DONE WEEKS GO UP
MY SPINE. WELL THAT'S LEAVE
WE'RE GONNA DO EVERY FOR
QUALIFICATION MAKE SURE WE GET
OF CALL CON HERE'S- QUALIFY.
THE TIME IN ORDER THEM TO BID
ON PROJECT WE INTO TO HELP PULL
CONSIDER THE APPROVAL OF DESIGN
YEAH THAT. IS THE JET BLOWING
THAT AN EXTRACTION AN ALLY OF
TWENTY TWO. SECOND MY
PRESENTATION THANK YOU THANK
YOU AND WILL SAVE THE QUESTIONS
FOR THE END BUT IF WE CAN ASK
THE NEXT THREE SPEAKERS TO COME
UP. VICE MAYOR SHELLEY MASER. I
AM GARLAND PUBLIC WORKS
DIRECTOR FOR THE SILLY CITY.
JUNE WERNER BURKE I SHOULD BE
ABLE SAM MY NAME'S NAMES
BOERNER HORVATH I'M DIRECTOR OF
ENGINEERING AND CONSTRUCTION
SERVICES SAN FRANCISCO
INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT WILL TAKE
THE THREE OF YOU AND THEN
CHRISTIE YOU CAN COME UP ON
YOUR OWN. DO A FOURTH SIX
ELEVEN CHRISTIE CAN IF YOU LIVE
WITH OUR CEO. OF THE PORT OF
OAKLAND AN OPEN INTERNET.
SOMEONE ELSE IS DOING THE FIVE.
YES THERE QUICKER THERE OKAY
PERFECT THANK YOU. RIGHT OUR
GREAT THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
HAVING ME HERE TODAY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH ESTEEMED
PANEL I'M VERY PLEASED TO BE
HERE TO REPRESENT THE CITY OF
REDWOOD CITY AND RECOGNIZE THE
CRISIS THAT WE'RE FACING WITH
THE POTENTIAL FOR SEA LEVEL
RISE ALL AROUND THE WORLD
REALLY BUT HERE IN THE BAY AREA
AS SUPERVISOR PINE- TALKED
ABOUT. SO REDWOOD CITY IS THE
THIRD LARGEST A WITH THAT'S
THAT'S MY JOB TO DO NOW HERE WE
GO. CITY THE THIRD LARGEST CITY
IN SAN MATEO COUNTY IT HAS
NINETEEN SQUARE MILES OF LAND
AND SIXTEEN SQUARE MILES. OUT
TO THE NEXT WINDOWS CAN SING
SQUARE MILES OF WATER IT HAS A
DEEP WATER PORT INDUSTRY
HOUSING AND PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE ALONG THE BAY AS
A QUICK NOTE IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN OUR PORT SIDE ONE
POINT THREE SIX MILLION TONS OF
CARGO WITH FOUR POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN REVENUE AND
CONTRIBUTED SIX HUNDRED FIFTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO OUR CITIES
GENERAL FUND SO UNDERSTANDING
THE POTENTIAL ECONOMIC AND
OTHER IMPACTS A SEA LEVEL RISE
OUR CITY HAS FORMED AN AD HOC
COMMITTEE TO ADDRESS SEA LEVEL
RISE AT THAT HOW COMMITTEE OF
THE COUNCIL WAS A CLIP TEND TO
COLLABORATE WITH THE REGIONAL.
ARTS AND THEIR NEWLY FORMED I'M
REGIONAL COMMITTEE. SO AS THE
FIRST ORDER OF BUSINESS THE
COMMITTEE TOOK A LOOK AT THE
POTENTIAL IMPACTS OF SEA LEVEL
RISE FOR CITY. YOU CAN SEE BY
THESE MAPS THE DATE AND TIME. A
NORTH AND BETTER. I WILL CAN'T
REALLY STREET BUT- TAKE MY WORD
DOES IN GREECE. I AM SORRY BUT
HAVE BACK JENNIFER BY FOR ON
THE TWENTY TEAM INSURANCE RATE
HAS BEEN OF SOME. THE WHAT AS A-
WITHOUT ASIAN FIRST THE ERROR
OF THE SAID WATER SYDNEY ONLY
IN CASE AND THE BILL TO RISE
SELAH FOUR THREE BUSINESS COPY
AND ROADS THE SHOW. WELL AND
WHAT HAVE A WE BEEN EXPECTED A
GOOD FOR OF OUR SIT AND THE
VAST MAJORITY OF BUSINESSES
WILL BE AFFECTED. THERE'S JUST
DEAD A SNAPSHOT OF ACTOR SO.
THEY ARE VERY BY USE REFLECT
DIVERSE REDWOOD CITY AMOUNT. IN
THIS IS ALMOST HALF THIS IS
**** ALMOST ALL THE PER WITHIN
CITY LET. IF OUT. AND THE
BRIDGES FOR THOSE WITH CITY OF
TEENS WERE FILE THIS IS INCLUDE
ANY OF THE POP RIGHT OF WAY IS
A REAL WHAT'S THE GOAL ONE A
ONE FOR AB WHICH MAY IT AREA
MUCH LARGER THAN CALCULATED.
OUR REDWOOD CITY GENERAL PLAN
DOT IS WRECKED AS A POTENTIAL
FOR LEVEL RISE IMPACT. BUT WE
KNOW THE IT CANNOT I'LL BUY ONE
CITY AND THE ZIP I MAKE PACKED
OTHER SO WE ARE FULLY IN
SUPPORT OF TACKLING THIS FROM A
REGIONAL PERSPECTIVE WHICH IS
WHY WE'RE PARTNERING CLOSELY
WITH THE ALL OF THE REGIONAL
EFFORTS. BY CONTRIBUTING TO THE
NEW AGENCY THAT WAS IDENTIFIED
ASSIGNING STAFF TO CLIMATE
READY SAN MATEO COUNTY AND
WORKING WITH THE OFFICE OF
SUSTAINABILITY AS WE'VE DONE
OUR VULNERABILITY ASSESSMENTS-
WORKED ON ADAPTATION GUIDANCE
AND MAPPING SEA LEVEL RISE. SO
I JUST WANT TO GIVE A COUPLE
EXAMPLES OF SOME OF THE EFFORTS
WE'VE UNDERTAKEN IN REDWOOD
CITY AS WE CONTINUE TO DEVELOP
AND THINK ABOUT THE IMPACTS. SO
HERE'S ONE EXAMPLE IS ACTUALLY-
I LIVE. KIND AND SHARE IT THIS
A NEW APARTMENT PLAQUES WERE
WORKS IN THE FIFTH IN AT A
STARTING OUT PATIENT TEN EIGHT
AND WAS REQUIRED TO RID OF IT
I'D AN ADDITIONAL FIVE FEET TO
THE LOWEST FOR. WHAT DID FIFTY
FEET THIS WAS DONE TO MOVE HI
DIED OUT OF THE FLOOD PLAIN AND
ACCOMMODATE SEA LEVEL RISE AND
WAS RAISED TO THE LEVEL OF
TWENTY ONE HUNDRED PROJECTIONS
IT WAS CONSISTENT WITH OUR
GENERAL PLAN WHICH REQUIRES NEW
DEVELOPMENT TO BE DESIGNED TO
PROTECT FROM POTENTIAL
FLOODING. RESULTING FROM
SIGNIFICANT FLOOD EVENTS AND
IT'S CONSISTENT WITH STATE AND
FEDERAL GUIDELINES TO CONSIDER
POSSIBLE SEA LEVEL RISE.
ANOTHER ACTION ROADS IS TAKING
LIKE EXERCISE IT IS ADDRESSING
OUR RV. TAX THIS IS A BET THIS
MAP OF SEA PORTS ARE SURE TO
SEE SENATOR MADE JUST A
REFLECTS PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP TO. CREDIT GEN THIS
DIDN'T LEVEES INTO BATTLE MR.
AREA TO UP AS WELL FOR THE IN
THE OUR OF CASH A NEW BELARUS
DISTRICT WILL BE FORMED TO
OBTAIN FUNDING AND REIMBURSE
THE DEVELOPERS FOR THE
IMPROVEMENTS. WE HAVE COMPLETED
DESIGN AND ARE OBTAINING PERMIT
SO SHOVEL READY PROJECT. AND WE
EXPECT CONSTRUCTION TO BEGIN
THIS YEAR WAS A PRELIMINARY
COST OF THIRTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS IT IS A SIGNIFICANT
PROJECT IN TERMS OF COST AND
REFLECTS THE TYPES OF
INVESTMENTS WILL NEED TO BE
MAKING ACROSS THE REGION. SO AS
SUCH WE CONCUR WITH REQUESTS
THAT I THINK YOU'LL HEAR LATER
FROM THE SAN FRANCISCO ESTUARY
INSTITUTE THAT THE STATE
CONSIDER MATCHING FINDING- TO
MEASURE A A. B. RESTORATION
FENCES SUPERVISOR PINE
DESCRIBED. PROVIDE FUNDING
SUPPORT LOCAL CAPACITY BUILDING
ADAPTATION IN PLANNING AS WELL
AS OFFERING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND IN GENERAL WE
SUPPORT THE INACTION OF THE LA-
RECOMMENDATIONS. THANK YOU. JOB
FOR RAIN TWO MINUTES UNDER THE
ACT THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
RECOGNIZING THAT. GOOD
AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU FOR
INVITING SFO TO SPEAK THIS
AFTERNOON ABOUT OUR SHORELINE
PROTECTION PROGRAM. MY NAME IS
JOE BEER AND THE DIRECTOR OF
ENGINEERING AND CONSTRUCTION
SERVICES AT SFO. WHERE'S MY.
THE SOMEBODY ELSE'S FIVE THREE.
THERE WE GO. WE. BUT OKAY WELL
I SUPPOSE AN IMPORTANT.
IMPORTANT PIECE OF THE
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR THE REGION IN THE NATION
IT'S ALSO AN ECONOMIC ENGINE
FOR THE REGION IN THE SEVENTH
IS USED FOR CARE. THE NATION BY
PASSED. WE SHOULD. FIFTY
MILLION PASSENGERS. FIRST OF
APRIL FOR IN DAHLE DIRECT CAN I
BENEFITS LOCALLY AND FIFTY
EIGHT. I SIXTY TWO POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS IN ECONOMIC
BENEFITS TO THE REGION I
SUPPOSE ALSO THE LARGEST.
EMPLOYER IN SAN MATEO COUNTY
OKAY THIS IS LIKE THREE SO I
SUPPOSE CURRENTLY AT RISK OF
FLOODING TODAY OF THE IMAGE ON
THE LEFT IS OUR- TELL. HIM IS.
APPS MANY CAN FOR YOUR OF AND
ON THE RIGHT IS THE THAT YOU
LOW RISE PRESS A FOR OUR IS
PIECE IS IMAGE ON SHOW. NOT
ONLY THE PHONE FOR WHAT. ARE
NAY. AND CAL RAINBOW. IT IS ALL
ONE TO US ALL RIGHT SO CLEARLY
IN HIS DECISION THIS REQUIRES.
OKAY SEE THIS RISK AS OPPOSED
DEVELOPED OUR SHOWROOM PROTECT
PROGRAM THE OBJECTIVE OF
PROTECT AGENCIES PRICE IN THE
HUNDRED FLOOD. GETTING US ALL
THE FOR THE FAME OF INSURANCE
RATE MAPS AND SURE WE HAVE A-
CHANCE. TAKEN IN A GROUP. INTO
A RETAIL SO. ALL THIS IS BEING
DONE. TO AT THE ABILITY OF THE
AIRPORT. WE ALSO NEED TO
CONSTRUCT A SURE ONE PROTECT
SYSTEM IN A WAY THAT MAX SAFE
OP. OF AIRCRAFT ON THE GROUNDS
TRAVERSING THE AIRFIELD AND
SAFE OPERATIONS OF AIRCRAFT
LANDING AND TAKING OFF AT SFO.
**** WHAT HAPPENED. I'M ALL
MESSED UP OKAY THERE WE GO.
YEAH. YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN THIS
OKAY I LOST I'M JUST GONNA FROM
HERE. THE FAA SAID STUDENTS
SINCE THE SAFETY PARAMETERS FOR
CLEARANCES REQUIRED. TO RUN
INTO WAYS. DOUBLE SHE IS.
LANDING OF LICENSE AND JUST
GAVE OUT PATIENTS GIVE BUT
EXTREMELY INSTRUCT AIRPORT.
ENGINE THE REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
MUCH ROOM FIRST ON PROTECT THIS
IS. IN ORDER TO DROP SAFELY AND-
IN THE OPERATIONAL FISHER OF
THE AIR FOR. ONLY NAY EACH OF
TELL THERE ARE REBEL OF THE BAY.
NEVER RIVER AND THERE REMAIN ON
THE BAY AS INDICATE BY THE CO
CHECKING IN THE DIE. WHAT YOU
CAN'T SEE. YEAH OUR SHORT TERM
PROGRAM WILL REQUIRE ADDITIONAL
THEY FEEL AT THE END OF THE
RUNWAYS BUT IS NOT SHOWN HERE
BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW THE
EXTENT OF IT AT THE TIME. THE
AIRPORT IS SUPPORT SUPPORT OF
NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS. WE ARE
NOT IN FAVOR OF THAT IN THE
VICINITY OF THE AIRPORT.
BECAUSE OF ITS FUNCTION AS A
WILDLIFE ATTRACTANT ESPECIALLY
AS IT RELATES TO BIRDS WHICH
CAN ADVERSELY IMPACT SEE FOR
COP CRAFT OPERATIONS. SO
BECAUSE OF THAT SO FOUR WILL
PROPOSE A HARD ARMORED SEA WALL
SOLUTION. OKAY FINALLY OKAY WE
THINK IT'S TIME TO CHANGE THE
MINDS ON BATES GILL WHEN THE-
BUDGET. EXISTING ASSETS FIRST
YOUR BASE. ENGINE LEVEL
DISCUSSIONS ARE ON THE BED TO
SIT IN MAY FORMS MICHAEL. IN
THE NOTE PRESS FOR NATURE BASIL.
TO PROTECT THE LOW PRICE WE
THINK THE ROOM. WE ALL MUST
ACKNOWLEDGE. BOB ONE THERE'S
NOT A ONE SIZE FITS ALL BLUE
PARDON BRING TEN GRAY AND FIRST
NEED TO BE CONSIDERED EQUALLY
AS AND VIABLE OPTIONS. AS WE
GET CLOSER TO SUBMITTING OUR
DOT SECRET DOCUMENTATION
ANOTHER CONCERN IS THE
REGULATORY PROCESS IN THE MINDS
OF AT ALL BAY FILL YOUR
NEGATIVELY. MANY SEA LEVEL RISE
PROJECTS WILL REQUIRE BAY FILL
PROJECTS THAT REQUIRE BAY FILL
SHOULDN'T TO PROTECT AGAINST
SEA LEVEL RISE SHOULD NOT BE
VIEWED IN THE SAME LIGHT AS BAY
FILL PROJECTS. FOR PROPOSED
DEVELOPMENTS. MEDICATIONS
ANOTHER ASPECT OF ANY PROJECT
THAT IS CONCERNING A DIFFICULT
FOR PER MATISSE CURRENTLY
MITIGATION IS REQUIRED TO BE ON
SITE OR AS CLOSE AS POSSIBLE TO
THE PROJECTED SITE IS TO BE
UNDERTAKEN INDIVIDUALLY BY EACH
PERMIT T. THIS IS A SPECIALLY
PRICED PROBLEMATIC IN THE
CENTRAL BAY WHERE THERE ARE
LESS MITIGATION OPPORTUNITIES.
THE MITIGATION PROCESS IS
CUMBERSOME DIFFICULT TO
IMPLEMENT AND ADMINISTER AND IT
CAN TAKE YEARS TO CLOSE OUT
PERMITS. WHAT SFO IS ADVOCATING
FOR OUR MITIGATION BANKS OR IN
LIEU FEE PROGRAMS SET UP FOR
PUBLIC AGENCIES. THESE BANKS
ARE PROGRAMS COULD HELP
MITIGATE MITIGATION MOVE FOR
ANYWHERE IN THE BAY ANYWHERE IN
THE BAY AS SHOWN BY THE COLOR
DIAGRAMS THE NORTH BAY IN THE
SOUTH BAY HAVE THE GREATEST
OPPORTUNITY OPPORTUNITIES FOR
WETLAND RESTORATION. REGIONAL
APPLICATION BANKS AND IN LIEU
FREE PROGRAMS COULD GIVE PUBLIC
AGENCIES OPTIONS FOR MITIGATING
THEIR PROJECTS TO GET AGGREGATE
REGIONAL MITIGATION EFFORTS OR
ACT AS A STEADY FUND OF SOURCES
FOR MITIGATION PROJECTS
THROUGHOUT THE BAY. WE THINK
THIS WILL BE ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT AS MORE AND MORE
AGENCIES IMPLEMENT SEA LEVEL
RISE PROTECTION IN THE FUTURE.
SEVERAL BELIEVES CHANGES IN
BODY FEEL POLICY AND PRACTICES
IN THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
REGIONAL MITIGATION OPTIONS
NEEDS TO START NOW. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING OUR
ENGAGEMENT ON THESE REGIONAL
ISSUES AND WHAT AND WITH THAT
WOULD BE BENEFICIAL TO ALL
PUBLIC AGENCIES TRYING TO
IMPLEMENT STE WILL RISE
PROTECTION PROJECTS AROUND THE
BAY. THANK YOU AND SORRY FOR
ALL THOSE STAFFERS HEALTH
PROBLEM HE MADE A VERY EXCITING
WE HAD TO PAY ATTENTION. I
DON'T KNOW WHAT HAVE. TO GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR ASSEMBLY MANNER
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AND SENATOR-
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
WERE HERE TODAY TALKING ABOUT
AN ISSUE THAT IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT TO THEIR SURVIVAL- OF
THIS CITY OF ALAMEDA AND YOU
MAY NOT KNOW THIS BUT- ALAMEDA
IS THE MOST POPULOUS- ISLAND
CITY IN THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY
AREA AND WE'RE PRETTY PROUD OF
A LOT OF THE WORK WE'VE DONE TO
DATE- ON THE SCREEN YOU CAN SEE
WE'VE RECENTLY ADOPTED A CLIMB.
IN AND RIP BILLIONS I AM I'VE
START ACTING. BECAUSE THE AND
IT COMPLETE AND WE'RE- LIMIT
YOU KNOW WHAT. OF THE SHIP WILL
BE BAD AND FOR HELP SO MISSING
US LOOKS ALLIED THERE WE GO
OKAY I'M DOING THE SAME THING
IS TO OUR- THANK YOU. OWE IT IS
IN. TO ABOUT SEA LEVEL RISE.
WITHOUT FIRST TALKING ABOUT
REDUCING EMISSIONS THAT'S THE
NUMBER ONE THING- THAT WOULD
BENEFIT ALAMEDA AND OUR GLOBE
IS IF WE REDUCE EMISSIONS
BECAUSE BY REDUCING THOSE A
MISSION OUR PROBLEM BUT SEE YOU
ARRIVE OUR LESSON. I IN THE-
FOLLOWING CALLED A CLASS SAFE
PATH. THIS IS JUST GOING OTHER
PEOPLE WHAT TO DO BUT IN OUR
CITY. GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
BY TWENTY PERCENT. OVER LAST
FIFTEEN HE IS- WE ALSO HAVE J.
THREE FOR TWENTY TWENTY THIS
YEAR ALL RESIDENTS. ARE YOU
USING ALL YOUR BAND CLEAN
ELECTRICITY ELSE AGAIN AS IN
YOUR FIRST TWENTY TWENTY A
HUNDRED AND CLEAN ACTRESS SO WE
ARE TAKING SIGNIFICAN I AM. TIM
SHORE THE SEA LEVEL RISE IS OUT
ON THE JUNCTION- ON THE FIRST
THE- THE SPECTRUM BUT A LOT
LESS THAN THAT WE'RE ALSO
WILLING TO TOUCH SOME THIRD
RAIL ISSUES ARE CLIMATE ACTION
RESILIENCY PLAN EXPLORES.
CONGESTION PRICING SO THINK
ABOUT AN ISLAND WE'VE ONLY GOT
FIVE OR SIX WAYS TO GET ON AND
OFF THE ISLAND AND WE'RE
WILLING TO THINK ABOUT WHETHER
CONGESTION PRICING IS A WAY TO
GET PEOPLE OUT OF AUTOMOBILES
AND INTO ALTERNATIVE. MODES OF
TRANSPORTATION THAT WHAT THIS
PLAN DID- WAS IDENTIFIED KEY
FLOODING LOCATIONS ACROSS OUR
CITY AND SO IF YOU TAKE THIS
MATTER THAT SHE DOESN'T DOESN'T
MOST HELLO THIS MAP RIGHT SO
LITTLE A LITTLE TIGHT- AWARE OF
OUR IT IS DOESN'T SCARE MOST
PEOPLE HOWEVER. OF THIS MAP
REPRESENTS- THREE IS A LOVER.
GET TECHNICALITY WORSE NOR THIS.
OF AT. GIVES WE SEE HOW SINCE
IF. THE FLY AND I WANT TO ADD
OF THE TO PAY. OF CLYDE THESE.
HERE IS OF THE BASE TO CONNECT
OUT OKAY THE LEAST TO TAP ABOUT
FEET OUT AND VEHICLE GO THROUGH
THEM EVERY DAY. I'LL BE WE HAD
A LOT MEAL PLANS AND THAT SHE
DONE ARE TUBES AND OUR GOAL IS
TO BEAT AIM UP RELY TOOK ME OUT
HOW TO AT TO PLACE TO USE IT ME
ABOUT OR MINUTES SO IN FUTURE
AT FEET OF C. LOVER WITH COMMON
IN AND HERE WE DON'T. REYES I
THERE ARE TWO. IN THAT INSTANCE
NOW HERE'S- MORE THAN THAT IS
THAT NOT JUST A FEW THE REST IS
A CURRENT DAY YOU'RE I MEAN IF.
FORM IS GET HAVE THE SAME RIGHT
OLD. IF THAT ON A FIFTY TERMS
TOM WILL HAVE BOTH A OUR TO OF
FLOOD. THAT'S THE SAY THAT THIS
IS NOT JEFF AND PROBLEM FOR THE
FUTURE BUT IS H. TO FOR MY TO
DEAL WITH LEVEL RISE IN A FEW
WE STATE WE DEAL WITH THOSE CAR
FUNDING- RISKS AB TODAY- IN
ADDITION WHAT WE'VE LEARNED
THROUGH THE ADOPTION OF THE
CLIMATE PLAN IS THERE'S ANOTHER
RISK OUT THERE THAT WE DIDN'T
KNOW ABOUT BEFORE- THIS PROCESS
AND THAT IS THE RISE OF GROUND
WATER YOU'RE GONNA HEAR A BIT.
MORE ABOUT THIS LATER I
BELIEVE- BUT ESSENTIALLY OF
SOME OF THE PREDICTIONS ARE
ACCURATE AROUND GROUND WATER
IT'S ALSO A MERGING IN THIS
SAME AREA OF BLUE- IN FUTURE
YEARS SAID THAT- THAT IS GOING
TO DEFINITELY BE A SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGE FOR US SO NOW WE'RE
GONNA ZOOM BACK OUT- LOOK AT
OUR ISLAND THIS TIME GOING TO
FOCUS ON THE RIGHT HAND SIDE SO
IT'S IMPORTANT IT'S IMPORTANT
TO KNOW. THAT BUT IN ADDITION
YOU ON THE RIGHT HAND IS AN AIR
OF OURS THE CALL BACK ARM IT
JEEZ. OF THE- ARE A LITTLE. OR
OUT IT THE NEXT WHY'D YOU SEE.
MAY A POINT OF IN AND DAY FOR
ALL OF THAT BILL. IS A IN THE
CITY OF A AS A WRITER THAT
BIRTH BE ON THIS AND GET BUT
IT'S NOT JUST THAT. THAT IT'S
IN ANOTHER CITY IT'S SO
CALTRAIN RIGHT AWAY SO YOU
HELP. TRANSPORTATION ALL IN
MAINE MEANS THAT- THE ROAD IT'S
IN ANOTHER CITY YET ARE.
AFFECTING OF. PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT STAKEHOLDERS IN OUR
LITTLE CITY- DE UM SO THIS IS
OBVIOUSLY A PROJECT THAT NEEDS
TO OCCUR IT'S GONNA BE A LOT OF
INTER AGENCY COLLABORATION
POTENTIALLY A REGIONAL
STRUCTURE COULD HELP OUT. IN
TERMS OF THE PRIOR TATIAN A
PRIVATIZATION OF A PROJECT LIKE
THIS NOW I DON'T WANT TO
OVERSELL THIS SO- FIXING THIS
LOCATION TERMS OF RAISING. A
ROAD THAT DOES NEED TO BE DONE
IT DOESN'T SOLVE ALL THE I'M TO
WORKING BY THIS HE- A TWO. SOME
OF THE OTHER A AREAS SLASH HE'S
SO IF YOU GO AROUND THAT AREA
BAY THERE'S A LITTLE AND THAT'S
WHERE THERE'S A COURT SEE ALL.
THERE'S A PRETTY DOPE AND AT A
BUT IS HE WORKED TREAT FROM
THAT'S ALL IT IS A FAIL AND I'M-
PRO. SIDE OF THE HILL WE'RE
GONNA ESSENTIALLY. PORTION OF
YOUR TO PAY. AND THAT A COME UP
THE HILL CREDIBLE LET OF SOME
KIND OF AN STRUCK TO PUT US
FROM THAT A RISK IF YOU TO SEE
LIVE AT SEA LEVEL RISE AND A
ONCE IN FIFTY YEAR STORM
TOMORROW NOW NOT ONLY THAT. OF
WERE NOT USING RICHARD EIGHT
WE'VE INVESTED ABOUT SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS OF
MONEY IN THIS PROBABLY THREE TO
FOUR MILLION DOLLAR PROJECT IS
GENERAL FUND DOLLARS WILL KNOW
HOW IMPORTANT BOTH AT THE STATE
AND THE LOCAL LEVEL THOSE
GENERAL FUND DOLLARS IN OUR
CITY COUNCIL HAS STEPPED UP AND
SAID THIS IS A WORTHWHILE
PROJECT AND OBVIOUSLY WE NEED
SUPPORT TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
RAISE- THE ADDITIONAL UP
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS NECESSARY
FOR THAT PROJECT. I'M MOVING ON
TO THE NEXT SLIDE LET'S KEEP ON
THE ISSUE OF FUNDING. I WOULD
WANT TO HAVE JUST. A GIPSON
ROBBERY RATES. FORMER MRS. OUT
A VOTE TO HAVE. HAVE A HE
DIDN'T OWN TACK DOLLARS TO
INVEST IN THESE PROJECTS WE
RECENTLY HAD A- WATER QUALITY
IN FLOOD PROTECTION INITIATIVE
THAT WAS SUPPORTED BY 57% OF
VOTERS A PORTION OF THAT MONEY
IS GOING TO THESE KINDS OF
FLOOD PROTECTION PROJECTS. ARE
CITIES ABOUT TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT AN
INFRASTRUCTURE BOND THAT MIGHT
BE ANOTHER WAY- TO FIND-
ALAMEDA IS PORTION OF THE
PROJECT HOWEVER ON THE NEXT
SLIDE YOU'LL SEE IF YOU LOOK AT
THE COSTS INVOLVED. UP TWENTY
ONE HUNDRED. TO HIGHLAND ALMOST
MILLION DOLLARS THE GOOD NEWS
IS. INVEST IN THAT MEAN DOCTORS
SAY. MADE OF WORDS OF EIGHT THE
END UP TO A GROUP ARE NOT ON A
MAN. YOU FOR IF YOU STOP PAYING.
PLEASE ENTER YOUR FIVE IN THIS
CITY BE IN AND TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED PROBABLY COULDN'T
COVER- THOSE THAT UP TO A
BILLION DOLLARS WITH THE COST
THAT'S TO SAY. THE WE'RE GONNA
NEED HELP- AND THAT'S I THINK
WITH THE STATE MIGHT PLAY A
ROLE BOTH IN TERMS OF AN
INFRASTRUCTURE BOND OR AT
RESILIENCY BOND- THIS NOVEMBER
HELPING STREAMLINE HOW CITIES
CAN TAP INTO THESE FUNDING
SOURCES AND ALSO RECOGNIZE THE
CITIES LIKE FOSTER CITY LIKE
THE CITY OF ALAMEDA WHERE
VOTERS. HAVE ALREADY SHOWN SKIN
IN THE GAME BY CONTRIBUTING
THEIR OWN TAX DOLLARS AND WITH
THAT. MY REMARKS ARE CLOSED.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME'S CHRISTINE
MCKENNON THE CHIEF OPERATING
OFFICER FOR THE PORT OF
OAKLAND. THANK YOU FOR INVITING
US TO PRESENT HERE TODAY SEA
LEVEL RISE A CERTAINLY WHEN THE
MOST PRESSING ISSUES THAT WE
FACE. AND WE CAN WILL CONTINUE
TO CONFRONT THE COMING YEARS
AND DECADES. AND IT'S GOING TO
TAKE PARTNERSHIP AS YOU'VE
HEARD TODAY SEVERAL TIMES AMONG
ALL OF US INCLUDING GOVERNMENT
AND PRIVATE INDUSTRY. AS A
LOCAL AGENCY WERE INTIMATELY
CONNECTED TO THE COAST JARVIS
SAM CISCO BAY. AND WE'LL SEE
MORE OF THAT IN THE MAPS AHEAD
AND WE ARE DEDICATED TO FINDING
CREATIVE SOLUTIONS TO SOLVE
THESE ISSUES. WE CERTAINLY
AGREE WITH OUR NEIGHBORS IN
ALAMEDA ON THE COURT IS ALSO A
COMMITTED- TO A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF PROGRAMS ON TODAY AND
GOING FORWARD AROUND CARBON
REDUCTION ELECTRIFICATION THOSE.
OTHER HERE TODAY BECAUSE WE ARE
TRULY TIED TOGETHER WHEN IT
COMES TO THIS ISSUE. SO FIRST.
SEE IF I CAN PUSH LATELY. OKAY
SO FIRST I JUST LIKE TO GIVE
YOU A QUICK BACKGROUND THE PORT
IT IS A BIT OF A UNIQUE
INSTITUTION WAS ESTABLISHED BY
THE WATER. IN NINETEEN SEVENTY.
HARTMAN OF THE CITY WENT UP DO
YOU HAVE A SEPARATE WHEN IT
TRIES. AGENCIES WE HAVE OUR OWN
APPOINTED BOARD. BUT THERE ARE
IS YOUR RESPONSIBILITY. IT'S
ALSO IT. MANAGED PORTION OF THE
TWENTY MILES OF WATERFRONT
BEGINS A VERY CALM PAGE TEXT IS
A LOT DIFFERENT. I WENT IN THAT
AREA IT'S ALSO POOR IMPORTANT
TO KNOW THAT WE ARE PART OF
STATE TITLES TRUST SO WE ARE
KEEPING THESE ASSETS AND
MANAGING THEM- IN THE TRUST OF
THE STATE. AND SO THAT IS AN
IMPORTANT COMPONENT BUT AGAIN
THERE ARE INTERMINGLING SO
PRIVATE PROPERTIES AND OTHER
PROPERTIES THAT ARE NOT TRY SO
VERY COMPLEX WEB OF
JURISDICTIONS. THIS GIVES YOU
AN IMAGE OF THAT. AREA SO YOU
CAN SEE AGAIN ACTIVE ON THE
UNDER WATER WATER AND USING A
G. PLAN YOU HAVE OR THEY'RE ON
A SOUTHERN PART OF THE- AND I
WENT CHAU REAL. PARKS
RECREATION. AND CULMINATING UP
IN NORTH AND- BY EMERYVILLE
BABY IT'S WITH FIRST WORK. IT
IS OUR TOP AND SEE THE THROUGH
THE AIRPORT CARRIES ABOUT
THIRTY MILLION PASSENGERS MAJOR
REGIONAL SAT. ADDITION
COMMERCIAL PULLS. HIM WE- I'M
JUST TOUCHING ON WHAT IS ASSET
MEAN TO THE REASON WHY DO WE
NEED TO THINK ABOUT IT ABOUT
IT- IT IS RESPONSIBLE FOR AND
SEE IF IT MOUNT ARMS. COURT
HONESTY'S BOMBS YEAH WERE CLASS.
SO THAT IT. COMPONENT OF WHAT
PROVIDE TO ME A AS AN AS A
WHOLE. WE HAVE A FIVE POINT SIX
MILLION IN THAT SPENDING WELL
IT WAS ALL THE STATE TAX IS
ALSO A THERE ARE A COME. BY AND
LARGE. FIRST I WANT TO JUST
TAKE UP TOWARDS THE AB SIX NINE
ONE SIMPLE STEP I THINK THAT
STATE SUBSTANCE WE AND YOU FOR
AT. WRITING DIRECT THE STATE
LEVEL. AND THIS IS GOOD BASED
POINT OF TIME TRUST RESPECT AND
IT'S IF WE WANT TO TIE INS
TRUCKS SO. AND OF WHAT QUERY.
NOW I CAN WEAR MEASUREMENTS
ACOSTA UP BETTER XIN STATE
THINK WILL BE VERY SMALL I'M
GONNA IT'S A LITTLE ON THAT
ADDITIONAL THINGS THAT WE'RE
DOING. WE'VE BEEN AT. THE X.
UPDATE ON THE WORK IN THIS
REPORT I DAY THE GETTING YOU
SEE WE HAVE OUR SEE. MRO BUILT
THESE TWENTY YEAR LOOKING SOME
TOUGH MAN ONE. ON THE NEED TO
BE KING OUT AND MISSING AND I
TWENTY ONE HUNDRED WERE REALLY
LOOKING TEN. MORE ROUTINE
INUNDATION IN THE- AREA AND IS
MADE HER MAJOR. AID CENTER FOR
THIS FOR THE COUNTRY OUR FIRST
EXPLORE THIS. IS AN EXPERT
WORKS REALLY UNDERSTAND WHY. WE
LOOK AT COMMERCIAL LET'S SEE AS
THE ONE PIECES ARE MUCH MORE
PLAQUE. WE REALLY MULTI ASSET.
WE DO YOU HAVE I DO ONLY
SUMMARIES HERE NOW THAT THE
EXPO TWENTY MINUTES MAYBE YOU
THE MOST UP. NOTED TOMORROW
VIEW THE MAN SAID- I WILL CHECK
INTO ONE AND I'M MORE SAID OKAY
IS WHAT I'M AND THEN THE PORT
ON THE AIRPORTS WHERE WE'VE
BEEN MOST **** YES MEN'S. WORK
TO DATE AND WE ARE SIMILAR TO
US- WE ARE SAFE. I. KNOW THAT
IS. WERE HELLO ENERGY BE ON SIX
NINETY ONE WORK DONE NOW OUR
OWN PLANET APPS WE ARE DOING IN
THE SERVICE MORE NORTH HONOR
THE I. SO OUR BELIEVE IT RIGHT
HE IS AN IMPORTANT PART OF
RESERVE AND SEES WHEN YOU. FOR
WE WANT TO BE MORE. I ABLE
HANDLE THAT STORM WATER THE
BILL TO PUMP WATER OUT SO THAT
WE CAN RECOVER QUICKLY AND HOW
BUSINESS NEW ANY. ON THE
AIRPORT ITSELF WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE STOCK ON JUDGES WILL BE.
CLOSELY OF A FOR ALL FROM
NINETEEN FIFTY SIXTY IN THE
SEVENTIES. WHERE ARE WE NOW
HAVE A- THERE WERE ABOUT
TWENTY. FAITH ONE BATTLE. WILL
GIVE SOME PRIEST. I KIND AND
FREE. UP IN ONE OF A TWELVE
BILLION DOLLARS PROJECT STARTED
OUT LATER THIS YEAR. ABOUT FIVE
TWO IS THAT WE NOT UNDER YET
FIND IT IN THAT WILL BE.
SENDING EVEN FURTHER RESIGN THE
AN ICE MAKER. A FITTING AS WELL
SO THAT WE ARE HOSTED ORTON ARE
JUST. IN ALL RIGHT NOW. AT THE
AIRPORT. SOME INNOVATIVE SHIP
IN ON WE ARE TRYING TO LOOK IT
UP IN LONG TERM IT IS ONE
INTEREST IT NUMBER IN OUR
SOFTWARE MUCH OF OUR AND THANK
YOU TO THE- REGULATORS B. C. D.
E. F. RECORD WHO WERE. FULL
SOME LIKE THIS IN I DO. ON GET
KIND OF WAVE IT AWAY SHE BREAK
WATERS WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE. WELL AS FORM A FOR C.
LIFE SO THESE ARE INTERESTING
INNOVATIVE AND CREATIVE BUT WE
NEED TO BE LOOKING AT
EVERYTHING WE CAN WE'RE
CERTAINLY SUPPORTIVE OF THAT-
YOU ALSO SEE HERE I JUST WANT
TO POINT OUT WE DO HAVE A LOT
OF WRECKED. TIONAL HARBOR
SHOPPING THERE AND SO THESE ARE
THE DIFFERENT COMP SOLUTION.
EMORY TERMINAL NOW IT AT AN
AIRPORT TERMINAL RUNWAY AND
THEN ACTUALLY THESE PARKS MEANT
BASED I DIDN'T ACTUALLY HAVE.
ON THEM AS WELL THE COMPLEX WEB
OF SOLUTIONS THAT ONE WAS
PUSHING TOO HARD. ALL RIGHT TO
JUST WRAPPING UP ON THE POLICY
IMPLICATIONS IN PERSPECTIVES I
THINK YOU'VE HEARD IT ALL HERE
TODAY. YOUR DICTION AGENT
BOUNDARY. WE'VE TO WORK
TOGETHER WITH THEM JOE IS IT WE
NEED IT LATER AND THAT.
PURCHASE ARE VERY. I MEAN TO DO
TO ME THAT'S MUCH MORE ALL
WRAPPED UP YOU'VE BEFORE WERE
IN ORDER GIVE HER AND WE'RE
ONLY A SMALL. WITH THE JUSTIN
BANK. THANK YOU I'LL I WOULD
LOVE HEARING FROM LOCAL TO SEE
THAT DURING SO WHILE AND IT
MAKES IT EASIER AS LEGISLATORS
TO SUPPORT YOU ARE WRITING
REALLY SHORT ON TIME AND I WANT
TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE ENOUGH
TIME TO AND FROM COMMENTS DO
YOU HAVE ANY QUICK QUESTIONS
FROM. OUR PANEL. WITH SOME
QUICKER ANSWER. VERY VERY QUICK
KRISTY LEE AND TALKED ABOUT THE
COLLABORATION CAME IN THERE
IMMEDIATE PROXIMITY JOE I'D
LIKE TO ASK YOU JUST HOW SFO IS
WORKING WITH THE SEA LEVEL RISE
RESILIENCY DISTRICT WHICH IS A
SAN MATTEO COUNTY COLLABORATIVE
ENTITY ENABLED BY STATE
LEGISLATION BUT AS OF- AS- AS
EVERYBODY IN THIS ROOM KNOWS
IS- SAN MATTEO COUNTY AT T. AS
WELL WHAT KIND OF ENDING IS
INVOLVED- WITH THAT DISTRICT
AND I'M CURIOUS WHAT THE
FUNDING STREAM IS FOR YOUR-
HARD. ARMORED YEAH WE'VE HAD
SEVERAL THINGS WITH THE FLOOD
BRAZILIAN STATES DO YOU RECKON
REVISED ON HIS LEADERSHIP SINCE
SAN MATEO COUNTY AND FANTASTIC
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THEM
AND DISCUSSING HOW TO MOVE
FORWARD- I THINK THAT'S A FULL
WAS A LOOK FURTHER AHEAD AND
SAN MATTEO COUNTY AND SPECIFIC
PROJECTS IN SAN MATEO COUNTY SO
WE'RE TRYING TO YOU KNOW KEEP
CLOSE COLLABORATION WITH THEM
TO MAKE SURE THAT WHEN THEY DO
START MOVING PROJECTS FORD WE
CAN LOOK AT DIFFERENT SOLUTIONS
THAT WILL WORK FOR BOTH OF FOR
ALL OF OUR AGENCIES FOR THE
CITIES. AND FOR SFO. AND THE
FUNDING OVER. THE FUND FOR THE
AIRPORTS PROGRAM COMES FROM THE
PARK REVENUE BONDS IS WHAT
WE'RE PLANNING FOR NOW BUT
FUNDING WOULD ALWAYS BE- HERE
WE WILL LOOK FOR OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES. AS WE GET TO THE
POINT WHERE WE'RE IMPLEMENTING
CONSTRUCTION. NOW IT'S STILL
YOU KNOW PLANNING AND- GETTING
READY FOR SCHOOL SUBMISSION.
JUST QUESTION WHICH WHICH I
DON'T KNOW COULD BE A KEEPER OR
WITH DOCTOR HILL NECKS AND
SHE'S GOING TO TALK ABOUT. BUT
IN CIVIL RIGHTS BUT WHERE WE
ARE RIGHT HERE. FOSTER CITY THE
FACT THAT IT'S BUILT ON PHIL
AND YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
PUTTING UP SOME LEVEES. AROUND
JUST TO A QUESTION ABOUT
GEOLOGY AND AM HYDROLOGY. WITH
LEVEES LEVEES OBVIOUSLY WOULD
SUPPORT SOME SEA LEVEL RISE AND
STORM. BUT I ALSO ASSUME THAT
THAT THE HYDROLOGY SHOWS THAT
THE GROUND WATER IS GOING TO
STILL NOT BE AS MUCH OF AN
ISSUE AS THOSE LEVEES GET OLD
OR WHAT ARE WHAT DOES THAT LOOK
LIKE WARS THAT'S A MAN DOCTOR
HILLS GOING TO BE. ABLE TO
ADDRESS BUT I THINK PUBLIC
WORKS FOR. HERE I'M I'M IN. I
KNOW YOU TAKE THAT INTO ACCOUNT
BUT- HOLY COW. IF YOU'RE WRONG.
YOU COULD SORT FLOOD FROM THE
INSIDE BECAUSE AROUND WHAT WE
DO HELP HAVE A SHALLOW
GROUNDWATER TABLE. FORTUNATELY
WE ALSO HAVE A LAGOON SYSTEM
THAT NOT ONLY SERVES AS AN
ENTITY BUT FOR STORM WATER
DETENTION. SO WE'RE ABLE TO
CONTROL THE- THE LAGOON SO ANY
WATER THAT COMES INTO OUR STORM
GREEN SYSTEM ENTERS THE GOON.
AND THEN AT OUR CORPORATION YOU
ARE WE HAVE A PUMP SYSTEM THAT
CAN DISCHARGE. THAT GROUNDWATER
SOARING TIRE LAGOON SYSTEM. IS
SIX HUNDRED AND SOMETHING
ACRES. AND HAS THE CUP SIX FEET
DEEP. AND IT HAS THE CAPACITY
TO HOLD WATER AND THEN
DISCHARGED SO WE DO NEED TO
RAISE THE LEVY TO KEEP ALL THE
OUTSIDE WATERS FROM COMING IN.
AND THEN WE HAVE THE LOGIN
SYSTEM THAT HELPS US PUMP NOW.
OKAY THANK YOU THIS IS THE
QUICKER CONTRIBUTION FROM THE
CITY OF ALAMEDA ON THIS- ARE AT
THE END THE RESULT OF OUR
GROUNDWATER STUDY SH SO. 25%
MORE LIGHT. THEN WE ADD. OUR C.
LEVEL THIS. SELECT YOUR SON
SOME SENSE OF THIS. OF PROBLEM.
THANK YOU MAYOR QUESTION WRITER
PINE THE NO HE- INTERLOCKING
ABOUT THE ISSUE RELATED TO THE-
EARLY SAN MATTEO CAN IS
APPROACH TO SEA LEVEL RISE IN
THE FUTURE RELATED TO RELOAD IT
ACCOMMODATE PROTECTED AND HOW
TO MOVE FORWARD WITH THAT IT
SEEMS A LOT OF THE EFFORTS HAVE
BEEN AROUND PROTECTING THE
RESOURCES THAT WE HAVE. THE
COASTAL COMMISSION HAS TAKEN A
DIFFERENT APPROACH I CAN ASK
YOU PROVIDE CAROL GROOM FROM
THE COASTAL COMMISSION IN TERMS
OF LIKE ON THE COAST SIDE WE
SEE A LOT MORE EFFORT OR AT
LEAST THE COMMUNICATIONS AROUND
MANAGED RETREAT. IS THERE. WORK
WITH THE COAST BECAUSE SOME OF
THE CITIES ARE BEING ARE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THOSE EFFORTS
THERE. RIGHT ARE AT OUR NEW-
FLOOD INTO A RISE DISTRICT
COVERS THE CO SIGNING IN THE
BAY. WE HAVE- TO REPRESENT
THOSE ARE BORED SO WE WILL BE.
DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
ASSIST ON ON ON ON THE CSIDE
ZERO WHERE THERE'S BEEN A GREAT
DEBATE THE CITY OF CHICAGO BOB
HOW TO APPROACH THIS PROBLEM
AND- WHAT IF. A PACIFIC IS
INFRASTRUCTURE. HIS HIS- IS
FINAL- YOU KNOW THERE'S GONNA
BE DIFFERENT SOLUTIONS FOR
DIFFERENT PARTS OF THAT'S THAT
STRETCH. I I'D THE CLOSE THE
COMMISSION HAS PUT A BIG
EMPHASIS ON. RELOCATION HAS
ONLY SO MUCH YOU CAN DO WITH A-
PERSONALLY OCEAN. TOM IS ALWAYS
GOING SOME NEW ONES IN THE
SOLUTION OVER THAT YOU'LL BE
ABLE TO WORKING WITH YES THANK
THANK YOU. WELL THANK YOU SO
MUCH I'D LIKE TO COOPER FOURTH
PIANO. AND I KNOW YOU'RE GIVING
US A LOT OF. YOUR RESPONSES TO
SEA LEVEL RISE WE ARE RUNNING
CLOSE ON TIME IF I ASK YOU KEEP
IT ON THE FOR FIVE MINUTES I
KNOW THAT'S- KIND OF
UNFORTUNATELY HERE AT THE END
SO WE HAVE TO SQUEEZE YOU BUT
IF YOU WANT MIND. I REALLY
APPRECIATE IT AND WE HAVE
CRISTINA HELL WHOSE ASSIST
PROFESSOR OF LANDSCAPE
ARCHITECTURE AND ENVIRONMENTAL
PLANNING. AND URBAN DESIGN AND
UC BERKELEY GO BEARS. AND LARRY
THE OLD SPEND AS ACTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE BAY
CONSERVATION DEVELOPMENT
COMMISSION. AND WARNER
CHILCOTT. EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO ESTUARY
INSTITUTE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
JOINING US.
OKAY GREAT THANKS
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY SPEECH YOU
TODAY. THE DOES GO FAST. GIVE
US A SALOON IT. OKAY SO I'M I'M
TALKING ABOUT GROUND WATER AND
I WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT I'M
TALKING ABOUT THE KIND OF
GROUND WATER THAT WE HAVE TOO
MUCH OF NOT THE KIND WE HAVE
TOO LITTLE OF I'M TALKING ABOUT
UNCONFINED WATER THAT JUST SITS
IN THE POOR SPACES OF SOIL AND-
NEAR THE AIRLINE THAT'S VERY
SHALLOW AND NOT A DRINKING
WATER SOURCE LIAM THIRTY IT'S
ALL THE WAY RENDON IS OFF
THREE. PARKING IT'S NOT
SOMETHING WE WAS A RE. THERE
WERE NO. JOINT FOR THE WATER TO
IS IN AS BAY AREA. WE MET A MAN
CLOSER BEFORE. ABOUT WE OWE NO.
SKIP AROUND. IT'S GONNA BE ELSE
THIS ONE IS SORT OF. THANK YOU
I'M JUST GONNA NEXT. SO WE USE
THE WORDS WELL DID THAT MAKE
THE FIRST MOVE WE INTERPOLATED
AMONG MORE IN TEN THOUSAND
WELLS. WHAT IS THE CURRENT OF
BROWN WATER IN SHALL COASTAL
BAY AREA. AND THE KIND SIGN. WE
FOR THE ENORMOUS. THE BAY N. G.
ALRIGHT AND WITH AND FEET OF
THE WATER IN A YEAR THAT'S ALL
THOSE WITH AN ERROR ON THE-
WHERE THE RATE OF CHANGE DON'T
HAVE DATA. SO THE TURBULENCE.
ALONG THE URBAN IS BECAUSE THE
BOARDS WELLS ARE IN AN AREA
WHERE THE LEAKY UNDERGROUND
STORAGE TANKS THE KIND. ONLY
THANKS. JUST KIND OF UNREAL ONE
MEET YOU SEE RIGHT ABOUT TWENTY
FOUR MONTHS OF WILL AND COULD
LEAD TO SEE WHAT PARRIS NOTHING
NEW WALL BUTTON IT WOULD BE
SPUR MY BY GROUND FIRE. THAT'S
EVEN IF WE WILL NEED ALL THE OF
THESE WITH. THING ON INLAND OF
ALL LET ME BECAUSE FROM WHAT
THE EYES THIS. SO YOU COULD
SPEND HUNDREDS OF THE OF AND OF
FLOOD ONIONS OF THOSE AND OF
COURSE SOME COUNTRIES PUMP- BUT
WE HAVE EXTRA PROBLEMS OF
PUMPING IN OUR REGION. IN THE
NEXT ONE. THESE ARE SOME
EXAMPLES OF ZOOMED IN ON OUR
GROUND UP TO SENATE CANNELLA
STRICT. AND WHERE THE BED.
WITHIN THREE IN THE FIRST IN A
WAY. DAY THE BLACK AIR SHOW.
THE GROUND WAS ALREADY CHARGE
INTO SERVICE STREAM OR ON. SO
THE- HANG UP THE GROUND KNOWS
WHAT SEASON. IN THIS OAKLAND
THE A LOT OF BLACK AND WHITE
BARRETT. WHICH WAS ARM OF BAY
AND THAT MEANS THE AREAS HAVE
GRANDMA ALREADY DID SELECT. ON
THE C. A LOT RED. HELLO COLIN
HIM STUPID SO WHERE THE BALL
FIELD THE TWO THREE HELLO THE
LAW. THE CALL HIM ALREADY PUMP
STANDS PLEASE. AND THE AREAS
AROUND BECAUSE THERE WE SHOP.
CNN THE DARK I'M SURE SHALL
ORDERED AN ON THE BOARD AND I
UNDERSTAND THE PART ALREADY
PUMPS BUT I DON'T MUCH OF IT AS-
WE CAN. THANKS A LOT. I JUST
WANTED CHAU AND AMP AN
ILLUSTRATION OF IT IS HAPPENED
SALTY ON WHAT. FROM THE OCEAN
SIDE AND PRESS ON THE WATER
BROWN WATER THIS LEVEL RIGHT IS
THAT IT USES. FRESHWATER JUST
COME RIGHT UP TO LET'S. THAT
MEANS THE SUIT HI GROUND.
ALREADY IMPACT BY WILL BE MORE
IN DID BASED ASIAN PEOPLE HE-
WATER WILL AT CREEK AREA AND
CALL US ON AND THEN THE SPREAD
OUT FROM IS TO ENSURE. THAT ANY
POLLUTION THIS BILL STILL CAP
ABOUT BUT NOT CONFIRMED HELLO
THERE'S A LOT OF THAT. THE
MOBILE SO WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT
HEALTH AND THE HEALTH THE BAY
AND IN RELATION TO THESE
REMOVAL AS CONTAMINANTS SO JUST
TO SUMMARIZE A GROUND WATER CAN
DO IT CAN CAUSE INFILTRATION OF
STORMS HI. BASICALLY I'M NOT
FUNCTION. BECAUSE INSTRUCTION
TO HIS WITH INCREASED ELECT
ACTION MISSION FOR ALL OF US
MOBILE OIL EMINENCE FOR A LOW
COST EMERGE THE SORT OF AND DID
WHAT. HE SAID WE- THAT'S THE
LAST OF THE IMPACTS ON THE
FIRST OF MAY ALREADY BE
HAPPENING WE'RE SEEING
INFILTRATION AND SEWER SYSTEMS
AND- WE ARE SEEING POTENTIALLY
GLOBALIZATION OF OLD
CONTAMINANTS. THANKS FOR. NEXT
SLIDE PLEASE THIS IS DOWNTOWN
OAKLAND AND IT SHOWS THE
CURRENT CONDITIONS ON THE LEFT-
SHOWS STORE YOUR LINE AND WHITE
AND IT'LL- SO ALL. AND SOME OF
THEM NINE. RIGHT IT WAS ALL
RESERVE BY RISING GRAY WATER
ARE THE BUILDING PRINCE EIGHT
AND FOUND NO GRANT ONE MEET
SINGLE PRICE. SO IF THE FLIGHT
WE GO BACK. EVEN IF FLOOD
PROTECT. I'M THE WATER IN THE
MERIT AS A TOP THERE NOW EVEN
THAT'S PER CLOSE SEE WE CAN'T
RIDE LIKE. ALL OF. OUR WHAT ALL
THOSE THINGS JOHN AND MIGHT.
THANK YOU NUMBER WATER TABLE.
THANKS THIS IS THE END DIGITAL
MEDIA AND THE AIRPORT WHEN IT
WENT IN THE FIFTIES ONE. THAT
WILL SHRINK MOST OF THE WAR TO
WAS MUCH SMALLER THANKS A LOT.
RECENTLY I'M NOT A LOT MORE
WE'VE GOT ON WILL SURROUND THE
AREA WHEN YOU PUMP WHAT WILL
COLLAPSE WHICH IS HOW. BELOW
SEA LEVEL PLEASE BE VERY
CAREFUL WITH PUMPING NOT TO
ACCELERATE SUBSIDENCE IT COULD
RAPIDLY DROP. SEVERAL FEET AND
THEN OUR OF FLOODING PROBLEMS
OF COURSE ALL WORSE EXCELLENT.
I JUST DID THIS QUICK
ILLUSTRATION A SHOW THAT IN THE
PURPLE YOU LEVEL RISE BACK TO.
OAKLAND IN THAT WHOLE RECTANGLE
THEM ON WHAT WILL ROB DOESN'T
HATE- AROUND SEE YOU ALL RIGHT.
ESPECIALLY YOURS IS CREEKS AND
THAT CALLS SITE GOING TO BE
VERY DIFFERENT. THAN A INTERNAL
WAY. ONE WE HAVE THIS SLIDE
ABOUT OF PREVIOUS CONTAMINATION
OF THE SOIL IN EAST OAKLAND.
SHOWS THAT WAS SO INTENSE TIONS
BUT EASE. BLOOD AND THERE'S A
RESIN AREA A THE- WERE.
ALTHOUGH ECONOMIC AND SO.
ALREADY BEING CLOSED I'D
TUITION. AND FINALLY ENGLISH OR
IN IS THE AMPLE THE SUN AFTER
WORKING INTERNET AND CAN. TO BE
ONE NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE ALL UP
AND SEE THAT POP SELECT AN
EXCELLENT. OR GROUND WATER MAP
SHOWS UP VERY SHALLOW WELL IN
MARIN CITY THAT'S NOT. THERE
THAT THE IT THE ART OF. WELL MY
THE NEW CIVIC. DOES NOT THE
RIGHT SOUTH BIXEL. AND THE CD
OUT ARE VERY WELL DONE. VERY
WELL STATED THAT. I DON'T THE
GROUND ARE IN TOWN SO BLOOM THE
ONLY CAN THANK NOT BUT DIDN'T
FEEL WAS ON AFTER THIRTY SIX IS
BUT I IF YOU HAD ONE I WANT
THAT THIS ONE OF THE LEVEL
BISON BLACK AND GRAY A SHOW FOR
THING FROM WATER. ONE FOOT NEXT.
TO FEED SELECT. IT SO THE THING
OCCURS IN THEN SIT NOW TAX ONE
WILL BE INTO TO WORK OR MORE OR
FREE PLEASE VENTURE REQUIRED
COMPLETE WEAKENED OF ACCESS TO
HIGHWAY AND THAT MORE PROPER
FORCING. SO NOT ALL BAD NEWS
OUR THING THAT WE CAN DO TO OUR
WAY INTO ADAPT TO A HIGH WATER
TO ANOTHER THE WITHOUT WATER.
ON SLIDE PLEASE. THEY BUILT OUR
PONDS AND THEN PUT TREE HOUSING
IN THOSE ARE SHOP. WHICH TO
SPEND STATE. SEAL A MODERN
DEVICE RIGHT THERE. SO PEOPLE
LIVE IN. SURE THERE WERE
WATCHING OUR CULTURE IN THEY
TAKE HOUSING PRESSURE OF OTHER
AREAS DESPITE THE SLOW HOUSE.
MANY MEMBERS OF THE OLD FOR WAR.
OR THE- ANGER HI AND THIS I'D
LOW. HELLO LETTING HER ON THE
SIDE OF THE FINGER BUT PEOPLE
WOULD HAVE TO DO IT AND STILL
GET AROUND INSIDE. WITH THIS
SECOND RECIRCULATE SO.
WATERPROOF PARKING GARAGES. WE
CAN DO. THIS LOOKS FANTASTIC WE
COULD HAVE THIS HERE AND THEN
THIS IS ANSWER THEM IN THE IS
THERE HELLO. THE STORY AB UNIT
WHERE PEOPLE TO YOU BOB. WHICH
IS A THE PONTOON FLOOR. HOW BOB
FLOOR WASTE SPACE PLANS. SO
THIS VERY WELL LIVE LOADING AND
WILL EVEN IF. SHARE DECKING ON
IT'S AN ALL SPREE AND UNIT
STACKED ON TOP THIS BOOKS
BECAUSE EVERY UNIT CAN BE TOWED
OUT BY A BARGE THESE ROLE TO
INTO BY TWO AND PLAY ON A FLAT
BED TRUCKS AND TAKEN TO NEW
LOOK SO WE DON'T HAVE LOSE
ABOUT. TO MAINTAIN. I THINK
THAT'S OUR KEY HOW DO WE
CONSERVE AL YOU WHILE WE ADAPT
FIND TO BRING THE PRIVATE IN
THE FUNDING EQUATION ALONG WITH
THE PUBLIC SECTOR. AND THEN
THIS SHOWS A CLOSE LOOK AT ART
MADE IN THE WRESTLING BY I'M
CHALLENGE ORGAN DURING THE-
LOOK THE OPTION. WE LOOK AT THE
TEN IN EAST ONE OF YOU
ARTIFICIAL EXCAVATED ON. THEN
FLOATING- STRIP. I KNOW IT IS
TO ON THE DAY GROUND. STILL
EVERYONE BE ABLE. ROB AN IN IN.
NEIGHBORHOODS THANK YOU. I WAS
EXTREMELY FASCINATING. THE FIVE.
TO ME IS A- DANGER DANGER. SO I
MILLER GOLD BAND AND I DID NOT
DO WAY PRESENTATION I'D PLANNED
ON YOU FLIPPING THROUGH SOME
PAGES BUT I DON'T EVEN WANT
THAT DON'T PASS AMOUNT DON'T
PASS ABOUT WHAT I'M HERE OVER
THE NEXT FIVE MINUTES
REPRESENTING THE ADMINISTRATION
THE RESOURCES AGENCIES TO
ANSWER SOME QUESTIONS THAT I
HEARD DURING THE PAST HOUR AND
A HALF FIRST OF ALL I WANT TO
THANK RACHEL AND THE LA FOR A
MARVELOUS REPORT WE HAVE WORKED
WITH THEM A LOT WE WORKED THE
RACIAL A LOT WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IN THE
RESOURCES AGENCY AND WE'VE ALL
LEARNED A LOT FROM EACH OTHER.
AND I WANT TO RECOGNIZE AS WELL
BORN IN. THE DC COMMISSIONER
WHO FIRST MAP WHEN I GIVEN A-
APPOINTEES TO BE. D. C. SO I
DON'T WANT TO DEAL. OR
DIFFERENT THINGS WITH FOR
DIFFERENT. THAT I HEARD FROM
VARIOUS ON THE- FOR FROM SAID
HILL. DO BEGIN. A GREAT. MY WE
LEARN FROM THE PAST WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE LEARN FROM
THE LESSONS OF THE WILDFIRES OF
THE PAST FEW YEARS WE NEED TO
PLAN NOW. AVOID DISASTERS. CAN
WITHOUT. MAKING ANY KIND OF
VALUE JUDGMENT WITH REGARD TO
THE DISASTER UP NORTH. WHICH
MANY OF OUR FAMILIES EXPERIENCE
FIRST HAND. I DO WANT TO SAY.
TWO FEET OF FLOODING IN. IN THE
BAY OR AROUND THEY WILL.
BASICALLY MAKE HOMELESS
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN SIXTY AND
NINETY. HOW YOU. PROGRAM AND
MANY IN THE BEING UNDER. WHO
WILL PROBABLY NOT BE A TO REACH
TO THE BAY AREA BECAUSE THEY
RENT AND WHO KNOWS SPEND THOSE
HOUSES WILL THEN BE FIXED. SO
I'M NOT SAYING IT'S WORSE I'M
SIMPLY SAYING IT'S REALLY
REALLY BAD SECOND WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE WE LEARN FROM THE
LESSONS OF EARTHQUAKE
PREPAREDNESS. PEOPLE DON'T
NECESSARILY PREPARE IT ALL YOU
DO IS SCARE THE- THIRD WE NEED
TO REMEMBER THAT EVERYTHING IS
CONNECTED PEOPLE TRANSPORTATION
WASTE WATER PARKS HABITAT. YOU
HAVE TO MAKE NETWORKS RESILIENT
NOT JUST INDIVIDUAL ASSETS IN
THE BIGGEST ASSET IS PEOPLE
RIGHT AROUND HERE AND MADAM
CHAIR YOU PROBABLY GOING TO SF.
WHEN YOU GO BACK TO S. L. O.
HELLO HI NO ONE IS RIGHT NEXT
TO SFO THEN LOOK AT ART YOU
HAVE TO FIX IT ALL AT ONCE. B.
C. D. E. IS REALLY BRING WHAT
ALL WITH. ON THIS. THE STATE
SEES AROUND THE BACK QUALITY
WATER QUALITY BOARD WANTED NOTE
MIKE MONTGOMERY SITTING RIGHT
BACK THERE THE NEW EXECUTIVE
OFFICE. OKAY SEE THE PART FISH
WHAT CALTRAIN. FOR HAS BEEN
TREMENDOUS STATELY COMMISSION
MOST OF. LOW THE- A BAD BAKER
WHICH IS LOCAL. LOOK PLANNERS
IN CHARGE SO ON. ALL OF US
TOUCH THE SAME PROPERTY HAVE
DIFFERENT AUTHORITIES BUT WE'RE
ALL ACTUALLY WORKING TOGETHER.
SECOND ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE IT
YOU SAID. OUR PEOPLE ACTUALLY
WORKING TOGETHER BECAUSE YOU
HAVE THESE DIFFERENT
JURISDICTIONS AND DIFFERENT. SB
CDC STARTED A REAL TRAGEDY AT
TATIAN. STREET GROUP WHICH IS
VERY VOLUNTARY VERY VERY
DIVERSE AND WE'RE GONNA HAVE A
WORKSHOP IN APRIL. DEDICATED TO
HOW WE'RE ACTUALLY HAVING A
STRATEGY REGION WIDE BECAUSE IT
HAS TO BE A REGION WIDE. ARE
HARD HELP DESK ADAPTING TO
RISING TIDES HELPED US SOMEBODY
TALK ABOUT UP HERE TALKED
ABOUT. THE SENDING AN EMAIL AND
NOT GETTING ANYTHING BACK ALL
YOU HAVE TO DO IS CALL BC DC
THE PHONE NUMBER IS. THREE FIVE
TO THIRTY SIX HUNDRED AND OUR
PLANNERS HELP LOCAL PLANNERS
EVERY DAY. WE ALSO NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE RECOGNIZE THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN LOCAL
CONTROL AND REGIONAL PLANNING.
BC DC'S PLANNING IS VOLUNTARY.
IT WILL REMAIN VOLUNTARY TO
HELP LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT. THAT
TENSION BETWEEN REGIONAL
PLANNING AND LOCAL CONTROL.
WELL IT MAY SHIFT A LITTLE BIT
CANDIDLY NOTHING AS FAR AS I
CAN SEE IS GOING TO AFFECT
LOCAL CONTROL AND WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE WORK THROUGH
THAT- FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MULLIN ASKED WHAT IS THE RIGHT
NUMBER FOR A BOND GREAT
QUESTION. MY REPLY IS ANY
NUMBER YOU WANT IT IS YOUR
RIGHT NUMBER THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS A NUMBER AND HERE'S A CARE
SOMETHING THAT I WOULD ASK. I
WOULD ASK IS A COASTAL ZONE
MANAGER THAT AS YOU WORK WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION ON THE BOND
YOU DON'T CREATE SOMETHING NEW.
IF YOU WANT TO HAVE MORE STAFF
DEALING WITH THIS PUT THEM AT
THE OCEAN PROTECTION COUNCIL
PUT THEM AT THE RESOURCES
AGENCY. PUT THEM AT THE COASTAL
ZONE MANAGEMENT AGENCIES PC DC
THE COST OF COMMISSION THE
COSTA CONSERVANCY WE'RE ALREADY
DOING THE WORK YOU DON'T HAVE
TO CREATE SOMETHING NEW WHICH
IS GOING TO MAKE US HAVE TO
LEARN HOW TO DO THIS. REALLY
REALLY QUICKLY. FINALLY LET ME
SAY THIS THE GENERAL PRINCIPLES
ON BEHALF OF THE NEW SOME
ADMINISTRATION. FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN MY SEVEN YEARS AS THE
HEAD OF THE CDC STAFF I WILL
TELL YOU THAT THERE IS A BREATH
OF FRESH AIR WITH REGARD
ADAPTATION IN SACRAMENTO AND
THE ADMINISTRATION. GIVE
GOVERNOR BROWN ALL THE CREDIT
IN THE WORLD ON MITIGATION AND
HE DESERVES MORE THAN HE'S GOT.
BUT THE NEW SOME ADMINISTRATION
IS TAKING ADAPTATION TO RISING
SEA LEVEL HEAD ON SECRETARY
CROWFOOT SECRETARY BLUMENFELD
HAVE STARTED TO WORKING GROUP
WHICH IS ACTUALLY REALLY
WORKING. AND THAT'S REALLY
THRILLING FOR THOSE OF US IN
THE BUSINESS DR MARKEL THE NEW
HEAD OF THE OCEANS PROTECTION
COUNCIL IS A STAR AND HE IS
MAKING ALL OF US WERE. THE
RESILIENCE BOND YOU SEEN THE
CAT CLIMBING LIST FUNDING YOU
SEEN AND WE'RE STARTING WORK ON
PUBLIC AWARENESS THROUGHOUT THE
RESOURCES AGENCY SO WE'RE ALL
TALKING WITH ONE VOICE ABOUT
THE ISSUE WE HAVE TO DO THAT.
FINALLY LET ME GIVE YOU THREE
GENERAL PRINCIPLES IT'LL TAKE
ONE MINUTE TO DO SO. FOR
PROTECT PEOPLE FIRST DO NO HARM
TO OTHERS WHEN YOU PLAN AND
WHEN YOU BUILD WHEN YOU PUT
SOMETHING DOWN IN THE SOUTHERN
END OF THE DAY IT DIRECTLY
AFFECTS PEOPLE NORTH OF THE BAY
REFLECTION OF WATER HAPPENS
WITHIN A BAY VERY VERY QUICKLY
SECOND BE PREPARED FOR THE
RESOURCES AGENCY TO SAY THAT
THE GOAL OF RESILIENCE FOR
TWELVE FIFTY SHOULD ACTUALLY BE
THREE AND A HALF FEET HIGHER
THAN WHAT THE ACTUAL GUIDANCE
NOW SAYS. AND FINALLY WE ARE
ALIGNING WITHIN ALL THE STATE
FUNDS TO THE SACRAMENTO AND
FEEL DISTRICT LEVELS WE NEED TO
LEARN HOW TO TALK ABOUT THIS
AND WE NEED TO PROTECT AND
EXPAND ACCESS FOR ALL. REALLY
PROUD TO HAVE WORK REALLY WELL
WITH FOSTER CITY ADD NEW SAW
WHAT THEIR PLAN WAS TO EXPAND
ACCESS WILL CONTINUE TO DO THAT
IN SPITE OF HOUSING SEALER.
THANK YOU. SLIDES OF THE STATE.
RIGHT OKAY JUST WAITING FOR THE
SLICE COME UP AND WHILE I'M
WAITING FOR THEM TO COME UP I
WANT TO SELL INDOORS 1100%
EVERYTHING THAT LOWER GOALS BEN
JUST SAID WITH ONE AMENDMENT TO
A FRIENDLY AMENDMENT TO
FRIENDLY AMEND THAT SO WHEN YOU
TALK ABOUT STAFFING I THINK IS
A STAFFING IT WE ABSOLUTELY
HAVE TO WORK WITH THE CESIUM
AGENCIES BUT WE ALSO NEED TO
PROVIDE CAPACITY AT THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT LEVEL SO ON START
WONDER SHOULD BOW- THINK LOOK.
NEVER IN THE HIT. WORLD LOW
MORE OF A BUSINESS. HUNDRED
LET'S HAVE THEM BUT WHEN I WAS
UNDER COUNTY SIGNED AND MARK
THE MEETING GET MUCH CREDIT THE
JOB. MAMA AND SHE'S PAYING YOU
WERE RIGHT ON THE ONE PART OF
THE REAL. FIVE MAYOR AND
THOUSANDS THE LEADERS ACROSS
PLAN THIS IT LEGISLATOR YOUR
SERVICE AS BIG OF THIS LEVEL
YOU OF ALL PEOPLE STAND BETTER
THAN ANYBODY ELSE. BYE BYE
COULD NOT BECAUSE HE I CAUGHT
DURING POWER THIS LOW. THINK OF
THE DAY I'M THE SENATE LET'S GO
ASTRAY ANSWERED SERVE IN THE
IDEAL YEAH ALEX JUST TIGHTEN
EATERS SEVEN FIVE CENTER FOR I
MIDDLE CLASS TWENTY YEARS BY.
LOCAL AND STATE LEADERS IN THE
BAY AND DELTA REGION BASED ON
THAT EXPERIENCE MY THREE POINT
MESSAGE TODAY IS TO INCENTIVIZE
AND SO WORK MATT EXCEPT BRIDGE
LINE OUT OF GEN PLEASE ENTER
ONE. EXPAND LOCAL CITY TO
COLLABORATE ON PLAY IT AND SEE
MORE TOURISTS CAN. CATION
PLANNING IMPLEMENT. TO I JUST I
AND ALSO FOR FRONT LINE LOCAL
LEADER. THREE SUPPORT. THE
FIRST EX RATE READ MORE LIKE A-
SHINING SHORT. THE BILL WORK
HIGHLIGHTS THESE GOALS AND ****
A HUNDRED DOLLARS IN VET TO
PUSH THE- STATEWIDE MAGEN.
URGENT OF THE CHALLENGE PLEASE
CONSIDER DOUBLING. THE MOUTH
THE AREA SUCCESS I. JUST A THAT
FUNDING IN THE BAY AREA WERE
ALMOST MILLION PEOPLE NINE
COUNTIES A HUNDRED WHAT CITIES
ESSENTIALLY IN A BATH OVER IN
WHAT WE FACE A TRIPLE THREAT
STEEL LEVEL RISES AND FLOODING
AND RISING WATER THIS MAP SHOWS
THE EXTENT OF THE BAY. COMBINE
THE LEVEL RISE AND LOCAL
FLOODING HAS KILLED. CAROL
NOTED RISING GROUP WATER IS FOR
THE COMPOUND THAT ALLEN
ASSEMBLY MULLIN NOTED THE
THIRDS OF THE STATE ENTIRE AT
RISK ECONOMIC ASK SHORELINE
ASSETS ARE IN THE BAY AREA
TODAY'S CURRENT VALUE OF THOSE
ASSETS IS CLOSER TO A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY BILLION JUST IN THE
BAY AREA ALONE. THAT'S WHY THE
BAY AREA IS A GREAT CASE STUDY
FOR THE TYPE OF SUCCESS LOCAL
OPERATIONS PUNCH STRING JUST
TAKE IT OLD IN A VERY LOW AND
WEBER PLANNING WITH SCIENCE IN
TECH SUPPORT. BEGUN TO THE FIRE
GOVERNMENT'S PERMITTED IN CLASS
PATIENT AN EXPLORATION SHIN BUT
WITH STATE COURT AGREED LOCAL
CITY WE'RE JUST BE INTO. THIS
CHALLENGE NUMBER. EIGHTY ABOVE
AVERAGE. HE WENT ALL FIND A
STRATEGY BUT WHEN TO RAISE.
RATE IS NOW COMPLETE BY IT AND
COUNTY. DURATION TOWARD THE
EIGHTIES AND ARE MET WALTON
TRANSFER AGENCY OR PUTTING ON
REGIONAL PLAN AND CONCERT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS SURE DOES SHALL
WITHIN. NINETY PLACE SINCE IN
ADDITION WOKE GOVERNMENTS TO
ORGANIZE ON THEIR OWN JOURNAL
WORKS TO SHIP DATA PORTANTINO
REGIONAL VERSIONS CHAU IS A
STRATEGIC INITIAL. BAY AREA
PUBLIC WORKS AND DOES WHAT
CONTROL AGENCIES BAKER IS AND
NOT OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT
PLANNING AND POLICY STUFF WE'RE
DOING. A TREMENDOUS NUMBER OF
ADAPTATION. I WANT ONE A QUICK.
YEAH THEY ARE NOT UP TO BALANCE
THIS IS COOL REALLY COOL AT SFE
I WE PARTNER WITH SPUR A BAY
AREA URBAN PLANNING RESEARCH
GROUP WITH LOCAL REGIONAL STATE
FEDERAL EXPERTS PRODUCE
ALISTAIR PROVIDES AN INVENTORY
OF REGIONAL SCIENCE LOCAL
DECISION MAKERS A SUITE OF
NATURE BASED GREEN AND GRAY
HYBRID SOLUTIONS TO PROVIDE
MULTI BENEFIT ADAPTATION
SOLUTIONS AND LOCAL. MAPS WITH.
SPECIFIC CHARLOTTE LIKE I'M NOT
GOING TO DATE ALL PASS THROUGH
THE JUST SO YOU. THERE'S FROM
ABOUT MAPS IN THIS THE PROVIDE
TWENTY SIX YEARS OF DATA
GATHERED THROUGHOUT THE BAY
AREA TO PROVIDE LOCAL PLANNERS
WITH REGIONAL INFORMATION WE
KNOW THE CLIMATE ADAPTATION IS
A REGIONAL ISSUE BUT 90% OF THE
LAND USE ISSUES TO DEAL WITH
REGIONAL ADAPTATION ARE MADE AT
THE LOCAL CITY AND COUNTY
GOVERNMENT. SO THE CHALLENGE
FOR CLIMATE ADAPTATION IS
ALMOST REALLY A GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE CHALLENGE HOW DO YOU
GET LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO WORK
IN A COLLABORATIVE. WHERE THE
HECK ARE WE GONNA FIND THE
BIRDS OF THE SAID IT'S GONNA
TAKE TO REBUILD OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE. MAPS NICKEL AT
THE IN THE- BAY AREA DEMINT.
THAT WE'RE DOING A GREAT OF
MINIMUM. SO I'M JUST GONNA GO
LOOKING THE CONCLUSION IS BUT
THE BAY AREA HAS DEMONSTRATED
EFFECTIVE COLLABORATIONS THAT
WORK AUSTRIA ACTIONS WHICH
NEEDS IT'S A TWO AND- LOCAL
CAPACITY. THAT COAST ON MANTA
BUT PART OF THE COASTAL
COMMISSION YOU DECIDE COSTA
CONSERVANCY TO DO THIS OF
CENTRAL WORK THE LA- REPORT
PROVIDES A FRAMEWORK TO SUPPORT
THOSE COLLABORATIVE EFFORTS BUT
MANY LOCAL AND REGIONAL PLAYERS
BUSINESS GOVERNMENT CIVIC ARE
POISED TO MAKE THIS A NATIONAL
MODEL PLEASE REVIEW AND
CONSIDER THE POLICY. THE LA A
REPORT WITH YOUR SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA SHORELINE
COMMUNITIES CAN BECOME A
NATIONAL MODEL OF HOW URBAN
REGIONS AT THE EDGE OF THE SEA
PROVIDE BOLD EQUITABLE AND
INCLUSIVE SOLUTIONS TO CLIMATE
CHANGE THANK YOU. THANK I WE
HAVE UNDER. TEN MINUTES LEFT IN
THE HEARING ON TWO ONE A LOT OF
TIME FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. ANY
QUICK QUESTIONS. AND QUICKER
ANSWERS FROM. AYE AYE. THE
ABSOLUTELY FASCINATING DOCTOR
WE SHOW THE PICTURES OF
FLOATING. HOME AT HOUSES OUT
THERE AND NOT ADVOCATING OR
SUGGESTING OR ANYTHING BUT
IMAGE TO ME CAME TO MIND OF
THE- FUTURE CITY OF DUMBARTON.
LEAVE IT. IMAGINE A WING. OKAY
THANK YOU SO NOW I LIKE TO CALL
PUBLIC COMMENT IF YOU LIKE TO
COME- SPEAK- PLEASE LINE UP
BECAUSE THE INTEREST OF TIME
WILL ALLOW ONE MINUTE PER
COMMON FEEL FREE TO DO LESS-
AND- COME COME ONE OF. THE
THIRTY. BECAUSE HI THANK YOU
ENSURE DEVICE MAYOR CITY OF
MILLBRAE BELIEVE IT OR NOT WE
ACTUALLY DO HAVE SHORELINE WE
ALSO HAVE THREE NEIGHBORHOODS
THAT FLOOD ONE HAS FLOODED
EVERY YEAR BECAUSE WE ARE
PARTNERS FOR LACK OF PARTNERS
ARE SAN FRANCISCO SFO SFPUC
CALTRAIN BARRED HIGH SPEED RAIL
AND WE CAN'T ACCESS THE AREAS
THAT CLEAN UP THE COVERS
SOMEWHERE NEIGHBORHOODS FLOOD
I'D BE A LOT MORE DIPLOMATIC
BUT I CAN'T DO IT IN A MINUTE
I'M SORRY CAN I DO THIS- ONE OF
THE SOLUTIONS TO HELP OTHER
FLOODING AND OTHER CITIES IS TO
DRINK HOME A CREEK IN THE
WETLANDS THAT. DIVIDE US FROM
ONE A ONE TWO BILBRAY ONE A ONE
TO TEN BRUNO YOU KNOW
REGIONALLY THAT'S THE RIGHT WAY
TO GO THAT WILL FLOOD MY
NEIGHBORHOODS. AND THERE HAS TO
BE. IT'S CROSSED INTO F. I AM
FOR. BECAUSE I SAW. OR NOISE
FOR TABLE I'VE BEEN ON IT FOR
YEARS WHEN I CHECKED THE OLD HE
I ARE. NOT ONE MITIGATION TO MY
COMMUNITY FOR INCREASED NOISE
FOR EXPANSION OF THE AIRPORT
BOTH FACILITIES AND RUNWAYS. I
AM SCARED TO DEATH THE WORK
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO DO ON. ON
A BAY RESILIENT SHE IS GOING TO
LEAVE MY LITTLE TEENY TOWN.
THAT HAS NO POLITICAL POWER OUT
BECAUSE OTHER CITIES HAVE MORE
POWER FOR US AND WE HAVE TO
SEPARATE FOR THE BETTER OF THE
REST. THANK MARKS. THE CIVIC
HAN OCEANSIDE I'VE PREPARED
REMARKS IN FRONT OF YOU. I'M
HERE BECAUSE- SEN TATIAN TODAY
WAS PRETTY SANTA OCEANSIDE AND
TO ALL THE BENEFITS OF THE- BAY
AREA RESILIENCY WORK WILL NOT
BE AFFORDED PACIFICA BECAUSE
THE GIRL IN THE ROOM THE
COASTAL COMMISSION WILL NOT
TOLERATE IT AND IN FACT IS
OPENLY AND PERSISTENTLY HOSTILE
TO CHARLOTTE PROTECTIONS. SO
I'M SORT OF THE CANARY IN THE
GOLD MINE AND IN THE A COAL
MINE. THERE IS A FACILITY- THE
RV PARK BE CLOSE THE COMMISSION
IS IN THE PROCESS OF PUNCHING A
FIVE ACRE HOLE IN AN EXISTING
ROCK ARMORING. AND WITHIN SEVEN
YEARS IT'S GOING TO BE ON
HIGHWAY ONE. SO WE HAVE A
SERIOUS POLICY DISCUSSION TO
CHANGE THEIR BEHAVIOR IF IN
FACT CHANGING THE COASTAL ACT
TO ENABLE THE CIVICA. TO BE
AFFORDED THE SAME PROTECTIONS
AS SFO IN GOOGLE HEADQUARTERS
WHICH WE DESPERATELY NEED
OTHERWISE VERY SERIOUS AMOUNTS
OF PROPERTY VALUES ARE GOING TO
GO IN THE WATER. THANK YOU. HI
MY NAME IS REUVEN EVERY COME A
COUNCIL MEMBER IN EAST PALO
ALTO NEXT TO PALO ALTO WHICH IS
IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY WHERE
ACTION SAN MATEO COUNTY TELL
YOU THAT YOU'RE- A VERY BRAVE.
AND COURAGEOUS COMMITTEE FOR
WHAT'S COMING UP IN THE NEXT
FEW YEARS I THINK THAT THIS IS
A VERY SERIOUS AND HAS BEEN
NEGLECTED FOR SO LONG. BUT I
ENCOURAGE YOU TO. DO EVERYTHING
AS A STATE- GOVERNMENT TO NOT
ONLY WORK WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT REALLY PUSHES
HARD. I THINK THAT SOMETIMES WE
GET CAUGHT UP ON IN OUR LOCAL
CONTROL. AND WE NEED TO GO
BEYOND THAT I THINK ALSO
WORKING WITH THE PRIVATE SECTOR
WE'RE RIGHT NEXT TO FACEBOOK
AND WE HAVE BEEN ADVOCATING FOR
MANY YEARS DAVID PINE. GORE
RICHARD GARDEN KNOWS THAT WE
GET FLOODED BY THE CREEK BY THE
TIGHT BY THE COMBINATION AND
NOW WE AND ALSO FROM GROUND
WATER. AND SO FOR US. IT'S
GOING TO BE IMPORTANT AND I
THINK THE FACT THAT FACEBOOK IS
RIGHT NEXT DOOR THEY'RE GONNA
HAVE JOINING. THERE IS NO OTHER
WAY SO ALSO I THINK PAYING
ATTENTION TO VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES THIS IS BEEN SAID
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
CONGRATULATE ALL THE WORK THAT
EVERYONE'S. HI GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS MERRIMENT TELE AND
I'M AN ENVIRONMENTAL SCIENTIST
AT THE CALIFORNIA COASTAL
COMMISSION ON OUR STATEWIDE
PLANNING TEAM. I'M ALSO A
RESIDENT OF THE CITY OF ALAMEDA
CITIES ARE VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUES- WE RECOGNIZE AT SEA
LEVEL RISE IS A STATE WIDE
PROBLEM IT'S COMPLICATED IT'S
EMOTIONAL- BUT OUR SOLUTIONS
WILL NEED TO BE LOCAL. I CAME
HERE TODAY TO LISTEN AND TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND THE VARIETY
OF. LOCAL PERSPECTIVES ON SEA
LEVEL RISE ADAPTATION. THIS CAN
HELP OUR STATE AGENCIES- AS WE
WORK ON SEA LEVEL RISE PLANNING
OUR STAFF WORKED CLOSELY WITH
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ON THE LEFT
RISE VULNERABILITY ASSESSMENTS
ADAPTATION PLANS. AND COASTAL
PROGRAM UPDATES. AND THE
COMMISSION HAS PROVIDED OVER A
THE DOLLARS PLANNING. TO OUR
AND LOCALS FOR OVER FORTY
CITIES AND COUNTIES OUT OF
SEVENTY SIX HAVE THESE GRANTS
ARE WORKING ON SEA LEVEL RISE
PLANNING. LYING TO HELP WE'VE
PROVIDED GUIDANCE ONCE YOU LOW
RISE PLANNING IN TWENTY FIFTEEN
WE UPDATED THAT WITH SCIENCE
AND WE'RE ALSO WORKING ON
GUIDANCE FOR RESIDENTIAL
DEVELOPMENT AND CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE.
THANK YOU MADAM TERRIBLE
COLLEAGUES AND EMILY BEACH THE
MAYOR OF CITY BURLINGAME AND I
JUST WANT TO ECHO THE PRES FOR
SUPERVISOR PINES LEADERSHIP. A
CEMETERY COUNTY IS KNOWN FOR
INCREDIBLE COLLABORATION AND
HE'S REALLY LED THE WAY WITH
CSC LEVEL RISE RESILIENCY
DISTRICT SO WE ARE ALL IN A
100% ON THE REGIONAL PLANNING
REGIONAL APPROACH. LITTLE
CITIES DO NEED THOSE STAFF
RESOURCES AT THESE REGIONAL
PLACES TO DO THE SCIENCE A WE
DON'T HAVE THE CAPACITY TO HIRE
OUR OWN STAFF TO DO THIS. SO
THE MORE YOU CAN HELP STAFF UP
AND- PROVIDE THE PLANNING IS
TREMENDOUSLY HELPFUL I ALSO
WANT TO ECHO THE COMMON ABOUT
EMPOWERING LOCAL IMPLEMENTATION
SO WHAT BURLINGAME DID WITH THE
REGIONAL STUDY THAT THE COUNTY-
PROVIDED WE TOOK IT HIGHER
CONSULTANT FOR A YEAR. STUDIED
ARE THREE MILES OF SHORELINE
AND WE DISCOVERED THROUGH THIS
PROCESS THAT YOU KNOW EVEN OUR
LITTLE SHORELINE HAS FIVE
DIFFERENT SEGMENTS OF WAYS WE
CAN BUILD GREEN LEVEES
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT CAN REALLY.
HELP THE SEA LEVEL RISE ISSUE
NOT ONLY TO PROTECT OUR
ECONOMIC ENGINE ON THE FRONT
ALSO PROTECT HIGHWAY ONE A ONE
AND THE CALTRAIN COURT WHICH IS
A STEP. ARE AND ALSO PLEASE IN.
I CALTRAIN. THANK YOU. THANK
MADAM CHAIR A COMMITTEE MANY IS
LINDA SHE AND I A RESIDENT RED
WITH BUT I'M SPEAKING TODAY AS
A CONSULTANT TO THE CALIFORNIA
OCEAN PROTECTION COUNCIL- AND
THANK YOU TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STONE FOR YOUR SERVICE ON THE
COUNCIL I WANTED TO TAKE OFF
THREE POINTS BECAUSE THE CDC'S
ELLERY GO SPEND SAID DID SUCH
AN EXCEPTIONAL JOB SUMMARIZING
THE REST OF THEM ON THE FIRST
IS THAT CALIFORNIA FIVE YEAR
STRATEGIC PLAN FOR PROTECTING
CAUSED AN OCEAN- HAS BEEN
CONCLUDING ITS PUBLIC COMMENT
AND UP FOR OPC ADOPTION. THE
MEETING ON SEPTEMBER TWENTY SIX
AND A COUPLE OF POINTS THERE IS
WE ARE PLANNING FOR- THREE
POINT FIVE FOOT TARGET PORTS
LEVEL RISE PLANNING FOR TWENTY
FIFTY AS WELL AS INSURING
ADDITIONAL THOUSANDS OF ACRES
OF COASTAL WETLANDS ARE
PROTECTED BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
ON THE EARLY SIDE THANK YOU YOU
IN THE LOWER PRICE SCIENCE FOR
STRUCTURE PLANNING SECOND ON
THE SEA LEVEL RISE GUIDANCE-
THAT GUIDANCE DOES HAVE A
PREFERRED AND RECOMMENDED. YES
CALL GENERALLY IS THE W.
DIRECTOR OF A PIECE EM CAN
ADDRESS ANY. AND THE FINAL ON
FUNDING WE SUPPORT THE BOND
MEASURE- PROVISIONS WITH REGARD
TO NEED TO BE SOLUTION THAT
SARAH BUT I WOULD LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT ARE YOU I WAS
THE OPC STRATEGIC PLAN
RECOMMENDS THAT THE COUNCIL AND
THE STATE CONSIDERED LOCAL LAND
USES LOCALLY AND IS PLANNING BY
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES AND
THAT THAT SHOULD BE AN EARLY
PRIORITY FOR- ALL STATE MEMBERS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS BRAD BENSON
AND THE PORT OF SAN FRANCISCO'S
WATERFRONT RESILIENCE DIRECTOR-
WE HAVE SOME PRETTY BIG EFFORTS
UNDER WAY ON THE SAN FRANCISCO
WATERFRONT WE'VE GOT. VERY
URGENT SEISMIC RISK WITH OUR
SEA WALL PROGRAM FODOR'S
ADOPTED A FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL
OBLIGATION BOND TO HELP WITH
THAT. AND WE'RE VERY HAPPY TO
BE WORKING WITH THE ARMY CORPS
OF ENGINEERS ON A FLOOD STUDY
FIRST AND A HALF MILES OF THE
CITY'S WATERFRONT. BUT I WOULD
SAY TO YOUR EARLIER QUESTION
ABOUT THE SIZE OF THE BOND.
IT'S THIS WORK IS
EXTRAORDINARILY EXPENSIVE FOR
THE NORTHERN WATER FROM WE'RE
LOOKING AT THREE TO FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS. WHICH EVEN FOR
A CITY LIKE SAN FRANCISCO WHICH
HAS A GREAT DEAL OF WEALTH.
THAT WILL OVERWHELM THE CITY'S
CAPITAL BUDGET AND WE'RE SEEING
THE NEED TO ADAPT OVER DECADES
AND SO THE WORK NEEDS TO START
NOW NOT JUST IN THE CITY AROUND
THE DAY. AND SO WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORTS HAVING
HEARINGS LIKE THIS AND- I WILL.
PROVIDE SOME INFORMATION TO THE-
THANK YOU I THINK EVERYBODY
HERE TODAY WERE OPEN UP TO THE
PANEL FOR FINAL COMMENTS I KNOW
WERE A LITTLE BIT LATE BY THE-
OPEN UP TO FIND A COMMON. NO.
JUST ONE FINAL THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AGAIN FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND MY COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR
THOUGHTS AND SOME INCREDIBLE
INFORMATION FOR THE PANELISTS
MIGHT TAKE AWAY URGENCY AND
MAGNITUDE ARE THINGS WE NEED TO
BE MINDFUL OF GOING FOR IN OUR
DISCUSSIONS JUST ONE QUICK NOTE
ON THE URGENCY AND LEARN TODAY
EVEN IF YOU WAIT JUST FIVE
YEARS ON WETLANDS RESTORATION
THE COST OF DOING IT DOWN THE
ROAD IS LIKE EXPONENTIALLY
HIGHER. AND MONUMENTALLY MORE
DIFFICULT TO DO JUST WITH A
FIVE YEAR WAIT ON A PROJECT
LIKE THAT WHICH CAN BE
EXTREMELY EFFECTIVE IN DEALING
WITH A LEVEL RISE SO I'M
FEELING THE URGENCY AND- ON
AWAY A LITTLE BIT FRANKLY BY
THE MAGNITUDE OF THE CHALLENGE
THAT WE HAVE IN FRONT OF US
BUT- WE WON'T GET ANYWHERE.
WITHOUT THESE KINDS OF
CONVERSATIONS OF THANK YOU.
AFTER. IF I COULD MANAGER I AND
I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT THOUGHT.
THE GROUND WATER WOULD BE THE
PROBLEM THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
AS WELL. WE LEARN MUCH TODAY
THANK YOU MA'AM CHAIR FOR THIS.
AND I THINK THE EDUCATION THAT
THE NECESSARY TO BE JUST WITH
COMMUNITIES IN THE PUBLIC AS TO
BE WITH THE LEGISLATURE. AND
THAT'S WHERE IT STARTED TODAY
AND THANK. SO I THINK IT'S ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT HAPPENED AT
THE LAST SYLLABLE RISE IN
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY. HEARING A
HAPPEN THIS TIME. IS WE'RE
LEARNING THAT AS OUR SCIENCE
UNDERSTANDING. OF SEA LEVEL
RISE INVOLVES. THE MAGNITUDE
AND THE IMPACT OF THE CHALLENGE
ALSO EVOLVES. AND SO I THINK IT
HAPPENED LAST TIME I THINK.
NUMEROUS OTHER CALIFORNIA-
WE'RE LOOKING YOU KNOW WE WERE
LEARNING ABOUT. YOU KNOW THE
AFFECT ON THE PLUS AND- THE
VERY LARGE MAGNITUDE OF. THE
LARGEST REAL COURSE SECOND
LARGEST RECORD IN THE ENTIRE
UNITED STATES. FALLING INTO THE
OCEAN. AND THEY WE LEARNED
ABOUT NOT ONLY IS AT SEA LEVEL
RISE AND BASS AND RISE. BUT AS
THE GROUND WATER INFILTRATION.
HOW THAT'S GONNA MASSIVELY
CHANGED INFRASTRUCTURE. I CAN
LOOK AT THOSE MAPS AND I AND I
KNOW I'M NOT FROM HERE. BUT I
CAN SEE HIGHWAY ONE OH ONE. I
CAN SEE PART AND WE SEE THAT
THE TO THE TOWNSHIP. SO WHAT DO
YOU HAVE PARKING THE SCIENCE.
LET'S MAKE SURE THAT WE TAKE
THE LA ROSA BEFORE AND WORKING.
AS A TEAM TO. ADDRESS THOSE AND
MAKE SURE WE'RE PROVIDING THE
RESOURCES. FOR OUR LOCAL AND
REGIONAL AGENCIES- TO REALLY
ADDRESS THIS. CRISIS NOW. WE
ARE TEN YEARS TOO LATE. AND
THERE. STATION THANK YOU TO ALL
OF OUR SPEAKERS TODAY OUR
PANELISTS. AND OUR AND OUR
MEMBERS OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE
WITHOUT AYE DURING THIS MEETING.